the Mandalorian has proven itself to not
only be one of the best original
offerings on Disney plus but one of the
best new shows on television period its
conflicted protagonist is a member of a
Dying race a warlike yet honorable
people who once inhabited the planet
Mandalore in the time of the Old
Republic during the time period in which
the series is set in between the
original and sequel film trilogies there
are people whose numbers are dwindling
fast due to a long long history of
conflict that has led them to being
forsaken by their own government and
exiled to the Moon of Concordia where
they were left to die out while the
history of Mandalore is a bit fluid one
thing that has never changed is the
Race's distinctive armor armor which has
been very familiar to fans ever since
the first big screen appearance of the
Bounty Hunter Boba Fett in Star Wars
episode 5 The Empire Strikes Back before
the release of the Mandalorian it was
even speculated by some fans that the
Title Character might actually be Boba
Fett as that character's Fate has been
reccon since his seemingly fatal Plunge
Into The sarlac Pit in Star Wars Episode
6 Return of the Jedi it turns out that
Boba is still alive meaning that he may
very well be wandering the Galaxy during
the events of the Mandalorian but the
differences between the two characters
are many and significant all of these
differences stem from the most obvious
one Boba Fett isn't actually Mandalorian
he's a clone of jeno fat who claimed to
hail from Concord Dawn a planet within
the Mandalore system although jeno wore
Mandalorian armor outfitted with the
types of bells and whistles common to
those worn by the Warrior Race he had
been disavowed by the Mandalorian
government which regarded him as nothing
more than a scoundrel a common mercenary
whose only interest was in a paycheck
this goes to the core of the differences
between Boba pet who followed in his
Father's Footsteps in becoming the most
feared bounty hunter in the galaxy and
the Mandalorian whose identity is very
strongly tied to his home world and its
culture what caused this
damage a mud
horn then you have earned the mud horn
as your
signant I shall craft it well both Boba
and the Mandalorian are seen operating
as bounty hunters and both operate
mostly according to the codes of that
profession that and their armor is
basically where the similarities end
this is because like his father before
him Boba Fett's code of honor is largely
his own untethered to any larger
philosophy which stands in stark
contrast to the Mandalorian whose code
isn't just a personal preference but his
actual religion in the series's second
episode The titular Mandalorian States
explicitly I'm a Mandalorian weapons are
part of my religion so too is Besar
steal the substance from which much of
the mandalorian's armor is forged and
which is considered by members of his
race to be a religious Sacrament POA
Fett by contrast has no such spiritual
connection to bescar his weapons or
Mandalorian culture his use of
Mandalorian armor and tactics is largely
an accident his father had used his
loose if even existent connection to
Mandalore to bolster his own reputation
and indeed his use of Mandalorian armor
was quite effective in Striking fear
into the hearts of his Quarry according
to Boba Fett's backstory though the
Bounty Hunter is essentially wore the
armor because his father did what a
daddy's boy one could certainly make the
case that the mandalorian's connection
to his dying culture and the ways of the
Mandalore make him a far more
interesting character than Boba Fett
ever was they may both be a couple of
bounty hunters in cool armor perpetually
on the hunt for their next job but the
mandalorian's reaction to the sticky
situation in which he finds himself
after taking custody of baby Yoda is
informed by more than his need for a
Payday it's informed by the strong sense
of Honor which is typical of all
mandalorians and it's even safe to say
that if Boba fat had found himself in
the same situation he might have decided
to save himself a major hassle by simply
terminating his green cuddly Target and
settling for the slightly smaller fee
bounty hunters we don't need that
scum the Mandalorian is a hit with all
ages but chances are that only the
adults in the audience will notice these
nods references and details from
references to Classic works of Foreign
Cinema to Star Wars trivia here are the
things only adults notice in the
Mandalorian although it takes place in a
galaxy far far away the Star Wars
franchise can be viewed as a study of
spaghetti western and Samurai movies
George Lucas has openly acknowledged the
direct influence films like Akira
kurasawa the Hidden Fortress and Sergio
leonis The Man With No Name Trilogy had
on his space cowboy stories likewise
Mandalorian Creator John favro has also
cited the two genres and directors as
major sources of inspiration for his
show he's even been quoted as saying
djarin is a deconstructed version of
Clint Eastwood's iconic Leone character
another major Mando inspiration is the
film series Lone Wolf and Cub sometimes
known as Shogun Assassin in the US this
classic story follows a disgrace
shogun's executioner forced onto the
path of an assassin he must take his
young son with him he pushes a little
one around in a tricked out baby cut
sound familiar although the Mandalorian
pulls heavily from the somber tones of
spaghetti western and Samurai films it
has plenty of laugh out loud moments too
particularly ones poking fun at the Star
Wars franchise itself these sarcastic
memes are all too familiar to mature
fans who have been dismantling all the
irregularities and quirks of their
beloved franchise for years one of the
more memorable of these tongin cheek
scenes occurs in chapter 12 The Siege
while Mando grief kaga kadun and the
unnamed mithil are infiltrating an old
Imperial base on Naro the crew
encourages the mythal to walk out on a
precarious ledge over lava to access
some Machinery controls to which he
replies that there's no guard rail the
Stark lack of safety railings on Empire
ships is something Star Wars fans have
been joking about since the first film
was released in 1977 and was most
notably mocked in the Star Wars Parody
episode of Family Guy Blue Harvest so
anyway I says forget the dental plan
forget sick leave I just want a railing
you know one railing right here another
hilarious moment of self-deprecation in
the Mandalorian happens during the cold
open of chapter 8 which shows two
Stormtroopers missing repeatedly while
firing at a piece of scrap within close
range the scenes playing on the age-old
Trope of the notoriously bad Blaster aim
for a guy who never shows his face
djarin is a huge chick magnet younger
viewers may not notice but mature
audiences will pick up on the fact that
excluding caraun the few non-
Mandalorian females he's cross pathed
with have either been instantly
attracted to him or had some sort of
romantic history with him in chapter 4
The Sanctuary didn't cross his path with
a young Widow named omera who seems to
want the warrior to settle down with her
bad boy Mando also seems to have broken
the heart of Xian a knife throwing Twi
he works with in chapter 6 The Prisoner
she threatens to use her blades against
him for whatever Shenanigans he pulled
on her in the past adults will likely
appreciate the sheer irony of seeing
comedian Bill bur cast in a Star Wars
related role longtime fans of his
podcast know that the snarky Bostonian
has long ried on the franchise as he
never forged a personal connection with
the original trilogy when it was
released in his youth bur stood up
controversy within the Star Wars fandom
for remarks he made in 2015 declaring
that when he did finally watch the
original trilogy in his mid-20s he
wasn't impressed I read a quote that you
had this is a while back I think you
called Star Wars a Cheesy self-help book
put in outer space with Muppet outer
space yeah to be fair Bill makes fun of
everyone and everything equally even his
beloved sports team still it may seem
curious that John favro would cast a
devout Star Wars hater in the
Mandalorian as it turn Al bur claims
favro chose him precisely for this
reason stating he thought it would be
funny Gina carano's background makes her
the ideal candidate for playing kedon
the most recent addition to star wars's
collection of fierce brunette heroins
before she started acting kanano was a
Muay Thai Fighter who launched her
career as one of the first mainstream
female mixed martial artists competing
back when the sport started blowing up
in the 2000s after earning an MMA record
of seven wins one loss and zero draws
kanano transitioned into acting in 2008
with the role of Natasha vova in EA's
realtime strategy video game command and
Conquer Red Alert 3 her ability to
perform her own stunts and make action
look realistic on screen has kept her
busy with various action roles since yet
another influence bound to be missed by
younger viewers can be seen in chapter 9
the Marshall in which Mando travels to
the Frontier Town of mos pelo on T
seeking out other mandalorians to Aid
him on his quest Mando gets sidetracked
helping the Marshal destroy a local sand
dwelling monster that has been plaguing
his town known as a greater crate Dragon
crate dragons are initially mentioned in
Star Wars A New Hope when Obi-Wan Kenobi
scares off a group of sand people
attacking Luke Skywalker by imitating
its Eerie hell a crat dragon's bleach
skeleton can also be glimpsed poking out
of the tne sand behind C3PO early in the
film however this terrifying BEAST's
appearance and the Mandalorian
references the 1990 sci-fi horror cult
classic tremis in that movie giant worm
like creatures called graboids lurk
underground waiting to strike their next
victim when they least expect it while
innocent young minds go no further than
admiring Gru's cool powers and cuteness
Factor adult Minds can't help but wonder
where grou came from if he's not a clone
as has been implied in the show thus far
then he was spontaneously created like
Anakin Skywalker or he was made the
oldfashioned way so far the only other
creatures encountered like grou in Star
Wars have been Yoda and yadle could
Gru's existence explain the latter's
sudden disappearance from the Jedi High
Council that all remains fan theory for
now but regardless of whose side of the
being formerly known as baby Yoda the
Twisted adult mind can't help but wonder
how such creatures would accomplish
procreation awkward it would be yes a
pleasant image it is
not unless you know some kids with very
strange and mature tastes they likely
missed a quick Mandalorian reference to
the classic comedy office space the film
parodies all the negative aspects of
toiling away at the dreaded 9 to5 Cube
farm from Horrible Bosses and wasting
away in traffic anyone who has ever
worked a less than desirable job can
relate to this movie Office Space also
makes fun of unnecessary corporate
bureaucracy and paperwork symbolized by
the dreaded TPS reports in the film it's
just we're putting new cover on all
the TPS reports before they go out now
so if you could go ahead and try to
remember to do that from now on that' be
great these reports seem to have made
their way into the Star Wars Universe
because mayfeld mentions them in chapter
15 The Believer it's such a quick line
and easy to miss come on let's go fill
out those TPS reports so we can go
recharge the power coil and you thought
the empire was evil before chapter 15 is
loaded with Quinton Tarantino references
mayfeld and Mando find themselves in a
dangerous situation while posing as
Empire Personnel an officer violent Hest
insists they join him for a drink they
risk exposing themselves while swapping
small talk but they can't break Rank by
refusing hess's offer so they agree the
suspenseful scene is reminiscent of the
hair-raisingly intense bar scene in in
glorious bastards both feature
characters infiltrating enemy cultures
while attempting to blend in as Natives
and both situations soon explode into a
violent catastrophe Mando and mayfeld
Frolic at the Empire Bar might also
remind an adult viewer of a scene from
Jango and chained when Dr Schultz gives
Calvin Candi a bullet rather than a
requested handshake just like Schultz
mayfeld is so overcome with lothing he
can't help but pull the trigger and thus
puts his companion in grave danger also
like candy has has a thick southern
accent and a Sinister yet lacad isical
demeanor a towering villain requires an
actor of serious skill luckily the
mandalorian's violin Hess is played by a
highly accomplished actor adults will
likely recognize Richard break break
succeedes in making his character
absolutely hateful but then as grown-ups
know he has a lot of experience in that
department break started his acting
career in 1993 with a small part as a
reporter in a British comedy Drama TV
series Jes and Worcester
since then break has performed in dozens
of projects and at least 30 Films
spanning o genres one of his more
memorable roles to date has also been
one of his most brief he was cast as a
night King in the fourth and fifth
seasons of Game of
Thrones during the first season of the
Mandalorian Star Wars fans were shown
the Galaxy from a whole new perspective
with many of the show's characters
providing answers to some of the
franchise's oldest questions and others
posing brand new questions for fans to
ponder in chapter 3 Star Wars fans got a
lot more Mandalorian than they bargained
for after turning baby Yoda over to the
client Mando earns a treasure Trove of
bescar Steel which he brings to the
mysterious armorer seen in the first
episode this draws the attention of
other helmeted mandalorians and one of
them isn't too happy with Mando
acquiring the bestar by working for
remnants of the Empire this scene
reveals a little more about the
Mandalorian culture while still raising
a few questions about their Creed
through during the brief melee between
Mando and his Brethren it's revealed
that the mandalorians follow a strict
warrior code this is the way take
Mando's refusal to take mud horn as a
signant because his victory over the
creature wasn't Noble enough or the fact
that other mandalorians compromised
their Hideout to fight for Mando and his
charge in spite of their earlier
hostility towards him these incidents
speak volumes to the mandalorian's
complex unyielding sense of Honor during
chapter 5 of the Mandalorian in the
show's protagonist is forced to land on
Tatooine after a ship is damaged in
battle with another Bounty Hunter the
razor Crest Landing awakens a small
Squad of slapstick droids whose design
you may remember from The Phantom Menace
in which the same pit droids appeared in
wat's shop while dormant the droids
almost look like metal Turtles but when
Jar Jar Binks unintentionally brings one
to life the young Anakin lets him know
that pressing their prominent noses puts
them back into their dormant State more
of these comical droids appear in the
Pod Race sequence during which they act
as clumsy three stoes esque Mechanics
for the racers Mando insists the human
mechanic P not allow any of her pit
droids near the Razer Crest and he's got
a couple of good reasons why obviously
he doesn't want any of them finding baby
Yoda and he's not exactly fond of droids
in general but Mando's also probably
aware of how remarkably bad the droids
tend to be at their jobs in episode 1's
pod race the Droids do far more har har
than good when their Antics get one of
their colleagues sucked into the Pod
engine of OD menril scrapping the
Dominion of aliens chances at a win
mingwen appears in chapter 5 as the
vicious fenic Shand an assassin who has
been on the run ever since the new
Republic imprisoned many of her old
employers it's not clear exactly who
those employers are but Mando guesses
they could have included the Huts that
seems likely considering she's hiding on
Tatooine which has historically found
itself under Hut control but the very
fact that Shand is on the Run suggests
that the Huts May no longer be in charge
and that's kind of surprising even
considering the recent fall of the
Empire sure Jaba the Hut died during the
events of Return of the Jedi but he was
hardly the only Hut you would expect
another would come in to fill the power
vacuum left by the crime Lord's death
the Huts operated on Tatooine free from
interference during the reign of the Old
Republic so why would that change with
the new one of course it's entirely
possible that with Luke Skywalker's ties
to Tatooine and his crucial role in
defeating the Empire the new Republic
gave the desert Planet a little more
attention than the other Outer Rim
worlds after Mando and baby Yoda finally
Blast away from Tatooine the show
introduces another character or at least
their feet not much is seen of the
shadowy figure who approaches fenic
Shan's body but it's a good guess that
they're stocking Mando and baby Yoda and
considering the prominent cape and the
Tatooine setting it's not beyond the
realm of possibility that this is a
cameo by someone fans have been hoping
would show up in the Series Boba Fett
now Boba Fett supposedly died in Return
of the Jedi when he was knocked into the
sarlac pit but in some versions of the
now non-canon Legends Universe Boba
Fett's armor helped him survive and
eventually escape the sarlac many fans
have been hoping the legendary Bounty
Hunter would eventually show up in the
Mandalorian and it's possible this is
who is seen examining Shan's corpse at
the the end of chapter 5 of course it
goes without saying that this isn't a
definitive Cameo by any means after all
it isn't as if Mando and Boba Fett are
the only Star Wars characters with capes
and any number of characters could be
behind the sneaky appearance the shadowy
figure could easily be John Carlo
Esposito's mysterious caped moff Gideon
for example or someone in his employee
and let's not forget that Darth Maul has
a tendency to show up when you least
expect him really it could be anyone and
even even the Show's first season finale
doesn't offer up any answers to this
question but considering the secretive
nature behind this character's identity
and the planet they're first seen on
it's clear that the show's creative team
at least wants the audience to think
this could be Fett the Droid known as
zero is the Razer crest's pilot during
chapter 6 but there's more to this
Sinister Droid than meets the eye for
one he's voiced by critically acclaimed
director and actor Richard aoad best
known for playing moss on the I te crowd
I came here to drink milk and kick
ass and I've just finished my
milk but there's also the type of droid
zero is it seems likely that zero is an
ra7 Droid or something very much like it
these Droids were largely used by the
Empire as spies and in spite of some of
his shortcomings zero does come off as
slightly more cunning than the rest of
the crew after all he's the only one who
thinks to examine the recording of grief
Cara's message in case there's something
important about it which obviously there
is it's also interesting that Zero's
immediate reaction to baby Yoda is to
try to kill him not to capture him and
sell him to the guild but simply to kill
him this could easily be down to his
former Imperial programming as the type
of droid that was used specifically on
clandestine missions you may know
exactly what baby Yoda is and what he's
capable of credited only as New Republic
Soldier the the soulfree human aboard
the prison ship before Mando and his
crew arried doesn't seem particularly
impressive at first he's as green as
baby Yoda but without the force skills
and seems about as capable of pulling
the trigger on Mando and his crew as he
is of pulling off that helmet so it
might surprise you to find that this guy
is actually Darth Vader well kind of
playing the New Republic Soldier is Matt
Lanter an actor with a whole lot of
Voice work under his belt including
voicing none other than Anakin sky
Walker on the animated series The Clone
Wars he voiced the would be Sith Lord
again in Star Wars Rebels and Star Wars
forces of Destiny as well as in video
games such as Star Wars Battlefront 2
and a number of the Lego Star Wars games
the sister brother Duo of Shion and
Quinn aren't exactly the most
sympathetic characters in The
Mandalorian Shion comes off as the kind
of killer who just laugh as she tears
her victims to Pieces while Quinn
betrays just about everyone in chapter 6
including the crew sent to break him out
and even his own sister however it does
seem like the pair have good reasons to
be turned cold and heartless Shion and
Quinn are twixs a race known for being
targets for Galactic slave Traders
female twixes in particular are sought
out because they're considered
physically attractive to many different
races and you might remember seeing
female Twilight slaves in Jabba's Palace
in Return of the Jedi or in Moss espa in
The Phantom Menace Shion hints that she
and Mando have been in inate in the past
and even implies she might have seen him
without his helmet but she doesn't seem
like a particularly reliable source
either while Quinn is seemingly dead by
the end of chapter 6 Shion is still
alive on the prison ship and it could be
that more about her and Mando's past is
revealed at some point later in the
series by the time Mando returns to the
space station after springing Quinn from
the new Republic prison ship he knows
he's got nothing but more betrayal
waiting for him he takes the tracker
that was triggered by the prison guard
before his death and plants it on quinnn
once Mando leaves the station ran orders
a pilot to kill him but the waiting
gunship never gets a chance Quinn
discovers the tracker and moments later
three X-Wing Fighters appear and open
fire on the Hostile vessel but the three
pilots who attack the space station are
all used to working on the other side of
the camera they are Rick fuwa Dave filon
and Deborah Chow all three have directed
episodes of the Mandalorian with fuwa
direct directing this very episode
meanwhile both filon and fuwa have
writer and producer credits on the
series filon has been with the Star Wars
Universe for a while in fact he oversees
lucasfilm's entire animation division
before the Mandalorian he worked as a
developer and supervising director of
the Clone Wars Star Wars resistance and
Star Wars Rebels when Mando returns to
the planet where he first meets caraun
The Rebel veteran is having a ball
brawling a spiky headed opponent Cara's
opponent is a dotham zabra a species
whose most famous member is Darth Maul
the resilient Sith Lord killed Qui-Gon
Jinn way back in The Phantom Menace and
was seemingly cut in half by Obi-Wan
Kenobi but miraculously survived and
showed up in both the Clone Wars and at
the end of solo a Star Wars story
because Sith Lords are super tough to
kill right Palpatine too soon it feels
too soon anyway this sabra's name isn't
revealed but in spite of kadun getting
the best of him he must be a resilient
sword as well the Sith wiped out much of
their race during the Clone Wars in
retaliation for an assassination attempt
on Count Dooku whether this zabra or his
parents were lucky and happened to be
offworld or if they managed to escape
the Sith punishment by other means he's
likely one of the last of his people it
may be a running joke that Stormtroopers
aren't very good at hitting their
targets but the kernels of truth that
make those jokes funny don't apply to
the death Troopers in chapter 7 of the
Mandalorian the Troopers in Black armor
who show up outside the client's
compound are death Troopers Elite
Imperial soldiers specializing in
stealth and trained to achieve maximum
body counts one of their main tasks was
guarding high-ranking members of the
Empire so the fact that a squad of these
deadly Warriors precedes MF Gideon's
arrival on Navaro speaks to just how
influential Gideon is if the death
troopers look familiar they should the
death Troopers kept Orson krennic
company through most of Rogue one a Star
Wars story they can be seen in the
spin-offs opening sequence when krennic
finds the erso family in hiding and
they're with him on scariff when the
heroes arve to get the Death Star plans
the deployment of the death Troopers to
the battlefield is one of the moments
that turns the tide against the rebel
surprise attack on the facility in
chapter 7 the mandalorian's main
antagonist makes his first appearance MF
Gideon and Gideon gets some more to do
in the show's finale including making a
stunning reveal that calls back to Star
Wars and animated shows some interesting
details about Gideon become clear in
chapter 8 first MF Gideon is apparently
presumed dead by much of the Galaxy when
Mando tells his allies who is waiting
for them outside the compound Cara says
it's impossible because MF Gideon was
executed for war crimes second it seems
that Gideon had a position of power on
Mandalore after Gideon reveals that he
knows Mando's birth name Mando tells his
allies the only record of that name was
in the registers of Mandalore and that
Gideon was an officer with the Imperial
Security Bureau during the Mandalorian
Purge but the biggest reveal comes after
Gideon's TIE fighter crashes on Navaro
Gideon Cuts himself free from the crash
with the dark saber a black lightsaber
that first appeared in the Clone Wars
animated series the dark saber was
originally held by tar vizla the first
Mandalorian Jedi the weapon changed
hands a number of times and was last
seen in the possession of Sabine Ren and
Bo Katan in Star Wars Rebels it's not
yet clear how Gideon got his hands on
the dark saber but considering the man
in question it's fair to say he probably
didn't get it by asking politely even at
the end of the mandalorian's first
season not much is known about grief
Cara's past obviously he's a man of high
rank in the Bounty Hunter Guild from his
dealings with Mando it appears grief is
a cunning intelligent Bounty Hunter who
will happily stab his allies in the back
if it suits his needs he does show a
spark of Honor in Chapter 7 however when
he saves the child and his protectors in
return for baby Yoda's saving grief's
life earlier in the episode season 1's
finale does offer up one big hint about
Cara's past though when moff Gideon and
his Imperial forces have the heroes
cornered he reveals that he knows very
specific information about them all
along with what he tells us about Mando
and Cara Gideon refers to grief Cara as
a disgraced magistrate grief being a
disgraced magistrate suggests that
unlike his allies this bounty hunter
once walked a much different path it's
not clear what exactly grief did to earn
his dishonor though he is seen reaching
for a bottle of liquor in his most
desperate hour it's entirely possible
that grief has a soft spot for a vice or
two never once touch my pum I go to Crow
service get some raw veggies bacon cup
of soup baby I had a St going chapter 8
opens the pair of Scout Troopers who
killed queal and kidnapped the child in
the previous episode waiting outside the
town in which Gideon has surrounded
the Troopers wait around for orders and
a comical scene unfolds with the
Troopers arguing about the child and
trying and failing to shoot at a piece
of rubble a
pet serves your right although their
helmets hide their faces the show's
credits reveal that the Troopers are
played by two actors more familiar with
the little comedy one of the Troopers is
played by former Saturday Night Live
writer and cast member Jason sedus more
recently known as one of the stars of
the 2017 science fiction black comedy
colossal the other scout trooper is
played by Adam P who Marvel fans might
know as Gary the cameraman from 2013's
Iron Man 3 the Tony Stark Super Fan who
helps his Idol with his news Vans
Hardware at first there didn't seem to
be much to say about the enigmatic
Mandalorian armorer who works with
Mando's best scar in the show's early
episodes chapter 8 however gives a
little more insight into the armorer's
past first it's clear that the armorer
is more than just a woman who fashion
armor and weapons she's a person of
authority within the Mandalorian culture
the first hints of this appear in
chapter three when she stops the
impending brawl between Mando and his
brethren in chapter 8 when the armorer
Tells Mando he must discover the child's
unknown species and reunite them her
word on the matter seems final this
would suggest her standing in relation
to Mando has an almost religious weight
to it like a priest sending a knight on
a holy Quest second it's shown that the
armorer is as much of a warrior as she
is an armorer when she rebuffs Mando's
insistence that she come with him and
his allies it seems like she's content
to die fighting like so many of her
fellow mandalorians but that isn't what
happens with nothing more than the tools
of her trade the armorer takes out an
entire Squad of fully armed
Stormtroopers armed with blasters don't
be surprised if this particular
character shows up again somewhere down
the
road the Mandalorian has the production
values and watchability of a Star Wars f
feature film as well as lots of subtle
references and callbacks to other Star
Wars media here are some Easter eggs
that even the sharpest eyed Star Wars
fans might have missed in the
Mandalorian the Mandalorian takes place
after the events of the original Star
Wars Trilogy and before the events of
the sequel trilogy there are a lot of
different races from a lot of different
planets interacting in the first episode
and many of them use their own distinct
language in a bar scene at the top of
the first episode a fearsome looking man
with an unruly beard beats up on a blue
skinned alien the target our protagonist
Bounty Hunter is after look at his
glands I bet we could sell them at the
Port subtitles tell the audience what
the bully says in an alien language the
guy tries to pick a fight with Mando
when he arrives asking if his armor is
Real vescar Steel the language he's
speaking is hes the language of the Huts
a Star Wars race made most famous by JB
of the Hut in Return of the Jedi after
the Mandalorian captures and carts off
his captured Target to collect the price
on his head in episode one The Prisoner
makes small talk with the stoic silent
Bounty Hunter back on his ship he even
notes that he was hoping to be free for
Life day then he stops talking when he
discovers Mando's other bounties frozen
in carbonite just like Han Solo in The
Empire Strikes Back what's life day it's
the Star Wars universe's equivalent of
Christmas a time for celebrating and
relaxing with loved ones it was first
introduced in the Star Wars holiday
special an Infamous 1978 television
variety show it follows Chewbacca's
family as they watch futuristic TV and
wait for him to arrive for Life day the
special ends with Princess Leia singing
a life day Carol life day isn't the only
Mandalorian call back to the Star Wars
holiday special we also see the Title
Character sporting a distinctive weapon
that should be familiar to longtime fans
of a galaxy far far away the pronged
rifle he wields at one point during the
show it's a cool looking apparatus us
with a long past in Boba Fett's first
ever appearance made during an animated
sequence during the holiday special he's
packing the same weapon it likely
doesn't mean much as far as a connection
to fet is concerned but it's an Nifty
nod to Star Wars lore episode 2 delivers
even more Vaguely Familiar entries in
the mandalorian's Arsenal during his
battle with the mud horn he fires a
small flamethrower mounted on his arm
that's apparently standard issue Bounty
Hunter gear as both Jango Fett and Boba
Fett have been picted with one and
various star warss media the first
episode of the Mandalorian is filled
with enough alien dudes and monsters to
satisfy any Enthusiast while it would
take too long to list every single alien
who appears in the show it's certainly
worth pointing out one of the most
surprising appearances of the episode
early on when the Mandalorian and his
Bounty are booking passage back to his
ship the Razer Crest they encounter an
alien hidden behind a pair of goggles
and a long snout he plays a killer flute
and we never learn his name but he
should be recognizable to any detail
oriented Star Wars fan this fellow was a
kubas an alien species who's only shown
up one other time over the course of the
Star Wars saga think back to a New Hope
specifically the scene shortly after
Luke and Obi-Wan meet Han Solo and
Chewbacca in the Alleyways of moss Isley
a kubas named garindan contacts the
Imperial Stormtroopers patrolling the
streets to let them know that he's found
the droids they're looking for if it's a
Star Wars property you can be guaranteed
that it's going to be swimming in robots
or as they're referred to in the
franchise droids the Mandalorian is full
of bleeping blooping droids in the
foreground and background doing their
jobs and staying out of the way of the
humanoid characters well
mostly oh no Bounty
Droid in one scene in the first episode
The Mandalorian walks through a
Marketplace one of the objects he walks
by is some kind of red and white R5
Droid it looks an awful lot like the red
and white R5 D4 model from Star Wars and
New Hope the one with the explosively
bad motivator another R5 model appears
later during chapter 5 in the Moss
Eisley Cana when the Mandalorian arrives
at the Fortified headquarters of the
client he's greeted by a round red light
equipped Droid tasked with security and
gatekeeping that looks and sounds just
like the security Droid job of the Hut
used in Return of the Jedi at the front
gate of his Palace until now the kawaki
and monkey lizard has had just one place
in liveaction Star Wars cannon as the
snickering pet of unsavory characters
like job of the Hut they're mischievous
they're obnoxious they seem well suited
for villainy and they're apparently
delicious immediately after the
Mandalorian gets his Bounty assignment
from the client he walks through the
marketplace of a desolate looking little
town one alien species stands out the
kaakan monkey lizard it's rough for him
too because he's being spit roasted
while his buddy looks on horrified from
a cage it's a bit of a horrific sight
especially knowing that these animals
are known to have a pretty
well-developed sense of humor while
everyone's favorite monkey lizard
salacious B crumb escaped Jabba's
insatiable hunger by having a special
talent for being a goofball these other
creatures weren't so lucky in episode 2
of the Mandalorian the one they call
Mando is keeping the asset safe
throughout a treacherous and violent
Journey this trip includes a runin with
the jaas a race very recognizable to
fans of Star Wars films for their hooded
cloaks and glowing eyes the Mandalorian
blasts any that could get in its path
turning them into nothingness as they
poof away without a trace later on Quil
tells the Mandalorian that the creatures
really don't seem to like him for some
reason mandoo
replies well I did disintegrate a few of
them this calls back to a brief Exchange
in The Empire Strikes Back between Darth
Vader and Boba Fett when Vader tells the
Bounty Hunter to bring back the crew of
the the Millennium Falcon Vader demands
that fet bring his quy back with no
disintegrations during the evacuation of
Cloud City on bespin in The Empire
Strikes Back a random guy runs into the
frame looking for a way out while
desperately clutching something about
the size and shape of an ice cream maker
nearly 40 years after the release of
Empire the third episode of the
Mandalorian provides a full and
compelling explanation for the Frozen
treat machine the Mandalorian returns to
the client to hand over the asset and to
receive his promised reward a camtono of
the precious metal bascar true to his
word the client hands over the bascar in
what looks like an ice cream maker the
Mandalorian is a working man before he's
anything else and while he's in
possession of a tiny adorable Yoda likee
creature for the first two episodes he's
also obligated to turn it over to the
Imperials who hired him but Mando isn't
a monster and he just can't bear to part
with baby Yoda after having bonded with
and developed an affection for the
little one so Mando attempts to retrieve
the baby and and as he looks for him he
spots a piece of metal pipe propped up
against a wall in an alley is that just
a random piece of space junk from this
post-war Galaxy not exactly it's covered
in ridges and Designs recognizable from
a very important piece of random junk in
the original 1977 in Star Wars it looks
just like the pipe that Princess Leia
Han Solo and Luke Skywalker used to try
to jam the walls of a trash compactor
they got caught it while the Mandalorian
boasts some star power the true breakout
character is the one colloquially
referred to as baby Yoda just like Mando
himself the little guy has won over our
hearts and his adventures alongside his
Bounty Hunter babysitter take up much of
the show's plot as far as we know this
adorable little creature hasn't been
given a proper name yet the online
community just uses baby Yoda because it
looks and acts like a baby version of
Yoda in the fourth episode of the show
though Mando does provide the child with
a nickname wamp rat it's a playfully
delivered pet name and one that has
significance in the Star Wars universe
in Star Wars and New Hope lukee
Skywalker brags to back on his planet of
Tatooine he liked I used to Bullseye W
rats in my t16 back home they're not
teers while some fans May argue on
behalf of the Enterprise the Millennium
Falcon is probably the most famous
spaceship in all of Pop Culture as
piloted by Han Solo in the original Star
Wars Trilogy its agility and Firepower
helped the rebels topple the evil empire
and yet it's an old craft long in the
possession of Lando calisan before Han
never had it and it certainly endured
some damage in numerous conflicts with
Imperial squadrons including Darth Vader
himself speaking of conflicts with the
Empire here's the atst Scout Walker
which attempted to lay waste to Endor in
Return of the Jedi in that movie Lando
refers to the Falcon as a hunk of junk
when the atst makes its triumphant
appearance in episode 5 of the
Mandalorian Mando takes a page from
Lando's book and calls The Battered
Scout Walker a hunk of junk as well
there's one other fun link between the
Mandalorian and land calisan the fourth
episode of the Disney plus Star Wars
series was directed by Bryce Dallas
Howard daughter of Ron Howard Ron Howard
was the director of solo a Star Wars
story which features young Lando as a
major character like many planets in the
Star Wars Universe tne has a large and
varied population of droids upon landing
at the planet's Moss Eisley Spaceport
early in the mandalorian's fifth episode
Mando is greeted by a couple of clumsy
pit droids much like the ones glimpsed
in Star Wars Episode 1 The Phantom
Menace and in charge of those pit droids
is a spaceship mechanic overseeing The
Landing Bay portrayed by comedian Amy
sederis under a lot of makeup and a
curly wig when Mando heads into the
space fort's Watering Hole to look for
work he finds more droids this is
notable because the establishment once
banned mechanical patrons as Luke
Skywalker learned when he tried to enter
with C3PO now years later droids seemed
to be fully welcomed there mingling with
the bar's expected variety of alien
races even the hardworking bartender is
a Droid and one of the same model that
joha the Hut used to oversee his robotic
staff back in return to the Jedi an
episode of the Mandalorian involving
Moss Eisley would be remiss if it didn't
include a sequence said in the
spaceports famous Cantina and chapter 5
delivers inside the place that Obi-Wan
Kenobi once called a wretched Hive of
scum and vity Mando chats with a young
novice Bounty Hunter named Toro cakin
the cocky aloof Young Buck definitely
gives off a Han Solo Vibe but maybe
that's just because he's sitting alone
in a booth in the canteen with his feet
up on the table Toro isn't hanging out
in the same booth that Han did but it's
very similar and just a few feet away
from the side of one of the most famous
scenes in Star Wars lore Mando finds
some action on Tatooine and he and his
new associate Toro cakan pursue the
Fearsome assassin finck Shand we see
them zooming off across the planet's
desert surface on a couple of speeder
bikes Anakin Skywalker is seen riding a
similar model in Attack of the Clones
just before he kills the group of Tusk
and Raiders that kidnapped his mother
Mando also encounters some of these sand
people approaching with caution to ask
for permission to pass through their
land they get to go ahead and find Shand
armed with a monster of a rifle She's
Got The High Ground she'll wait for us
to make the first move Mando tells Toro
that is a subtle winking nod to a
similar thing that Obi-Wan Kenobi says
to Anakin Skywalker during their big
lightsaber showdown in Revenge of the
Sith when Kenobi claims he has The High
Ground eventually the two bounty hunters
get the upper hand and manage to capture
Shand they decide to keep her alive
because as Mando says she's no good to
us
dead the phrasing reminds us of
something Mando's fellow masked Bounty
Hunter boa Fett says to Darth Vader and
The Empire Strikes Back when Vader
decides to put Solo in carbonite the
Bounty Hunter reminds the Dark Lord that
solo is no good to me dead the
Mandalorian has welcomed a number of
comedians to its cast and supporting
roles and Bill Burr arrives in chapter 6
The Prisoner the motor mouth standup is
a perfect fit for the roll of Mayfield
part of the crack mercenary team hired
by Mando's former cohort ranzar ran Mal
to bust one of his Pals out of the
prison ship on the way to that gig
Mayfield and fellow MC Shian addressed
the elephant in the room what exactly
Mando looks like under that helmet
Mayfield imbued with Burr's comic Spirit
jokes that Mando must wear a helmet to
hide the fact that he's a gungan it's a
crude reference to arguably one of the
most loathed characters in all of Star
Wars Jar Jar Binks the goofy gungan who
played such a major role in The Phantom
Menace the sixth episode of the
Mandalorian is particularly full of
appearances by notable contributors to
past Star Wars media one of the members
of the prison break super group ran
assembles is a devonian named Berg under
all that makeup is clany brown a
character actor with more than 250
acting credits not the least of which is
voicing Mr Krabs on SpongeBob
SquarePants he's also done quite a few
Star Wars voices including Darth Maul's
brother Savage oppress on the Clone Wars
and rebel leader writer aandi on Star
Wars Rebels another veteran of the Clone
Wars animated series also pops up in
episode 6 that doomed New Republic
trooper on the prison ship is played by
Matt Lanter the voice of animated Anakin
Skywalker lanter has voiced the man who
would be Darth Vader in more than 100
television episodes which means he's
played the part more than any other
actor the Mandalorian is full of nods to
Star Wars past whether they're tributes
to the original trilogy the prequel
trilogy or Beyond in chapter 6 though
the show also makes time to pay tribute
to the people who made the Mandalorian
itself when the mercenary crew arrives
on the prison ship for the task at hand
they walk past a cell that contains a
four armed monkey-like creature that
belongs to the ardanian race that
species is a relatively new addition to
the Star Wars cannon the alien first
appeared in Solo a Star Wars story in
2018 in the form of pilot Rio Durant Rio
was voiced by John favro the Creator and
executive producer of the Mandalorian
those X-Wing fighters who make an
explosive appearance at the end of the
episode are named jib Dodger sash
Kettler and Trapper wolf they're
portrayed by Rick fuya De chow and Dave
filon all of them directors of various
episodes of the Mandalorian the opening
of the mandalorian's first season finale
offers a bit of much-needed comic relief
to cut the high stakes tension set up by
the last episode it also offers a bit of
a call back to a joke from a previous
episode about a beloved part of Star
Wars lore remember in chapter 6 when the
mercenary Mayfield took offense at being
compared to a stormtrooper it's because
Stormtroopers are notoriously terrible
shots the two speedier bike riding Scout
Troopers shown in episode 8 of the
Mandalorian can't hit anything either
even when firing their blasters in a low
stakes no stress situation they're
firing a piece of debris just because
they're bored and they still can't hit a
thing
in the eighth and final episode of the
mandalorian's first season viewers
finally get an information dump of
background info on the mysterious and
compelling ex-rebel fighter Cara Dune
one major Little Nugget as revealed by
MF Gideon is that the former Rebel Shock
Trooper hails from the planet alderon
the home planet of Princess Leia or at
least it was the home of Princess Leia
until it was destroyed by the Death Star
back in Star Wars A New Hope craving
Justice for her people would have been a
pretty motivating factor for Cara Dune
who then decided to become an active
member of the Rebellion because of her
Rebel history Cara also mentions her
fear of getting interrogated with a mind
flare that's more of a horror fantasy
term like something out of stranger
things but in the Star Wars Universe
Cara is most likely referring to
something like the Bor gullet that's the
purple skinned psychic creature that
painfully interrogated bod rook in Rogue
one it's basically an alien lie detector
while also breaking someone's brain as
it works
in a major moment of the Mandalorian
chapter 8 Mo Gideon cuts a path to
Freedom out of his downed TIE fighter
with the use of a lightsaber but this is
not just any lightsaber it's a black
lightsaber as it isn't cast in a
customary neon shade this is a very cool
looking Star Wars weapon and also an
instant indication that moth Gideon is
truly a dark force to be feared his dark
saber as well the dark saber the
ceremonial weapon traditionally bestowed
on the leader of Mandalore for first
forged by an ancient Mandalorian Jedi
it's popped up throughout the Star Wars
animated Cannon it was last seen on Star
Wars Rebels when Rebel fighter Sabine
Ren passed it along to death watch
leader bokatan to more effectively fight
the Empire the fact that M Gideon now
has this coveted weapon is bad news all
around as he's an imperial die hard that
means good guy or perhaps a lot of good
guys had to die for Gideon to get his
hands on this all poses a lot of
questions which can only be answered by
another another season of the
Mandalorian set 3 years after the Return
of the Jedi the Disney plus Star Wars
series The Mandalorian follows a lone
Gunslinger who works outside of the law
the cast features actors from the world
of Game of Thrones The X-Men universe
and even the Rocky movies here's how you
might know them from the moment that
Pedro Pascal's Prince Ober and Martell
stred into King's Landing Game of
Thrones gained a new fan favorite
character you shouldn't drink before a
fight you learned this during your years
in the fighting pits I always drink
before a fight as The Red Viper Pascal
was able to leave an extremely memorable
mark on the series especially with his
Grizzly death Pascal has also had a slew
of minor roles in television including
playing Nathan laundry and The Good Wife
he also played Javier Pena in the
Netflix original series narcos as for
noteworthy movies Pascal appeared in the
action flick Kingsmen the Golden Circle
and the drama if Bei Street could talk
at 2019 Star Wars celebration in Chicago
Pascal briefly touched on his upcoming
role in the Mandalorian in which he
plays the protagonist saying the
Mandalorian is a mysterious lone gunman
in the outer reaches of the Galaxy some
might say that he has questionable moral
character which is in line with some of
our Best Westerns some good Samurai
films and he's a badass in this day and
age it's not uncommon for famous MMA
fighters to make the transition to
acting add Gina corano to the list
carano's first leading role came in 2011
when she played mallerie Kane in the
adrenaline pumping action movie Haywire
since then she has played minor Parts in
a couple of blockbusters smashes
including 2013's Fast infurious 6 and
2016's Deadpool in the Mandalorian
corano will be playing Cara dun an
ex-rebel Shock Trooper who is apparently
having some trouble reintegrating into
society after the last big star war
although not much is known of her
character kanano took to Instagram and
shared the first image of her character
commenting about her time at Star Wars
celebration she wrote I Can't Describe
the energy I felt it was incredible and
I'm so grateful for all of you and the
crazy awesome support you showed us I'm
so stoked that was epic Carl Weathers is
a Hollywood icon with a well-rounded
acting resume of notable roles including
Apollo Creed in the Rocky franchise and
Dylan in Predator in the 90s he embodied
the hilarious golf legend turned coach
chubs Peterson in Adam Sandler's
Timeless comedy Happy Gilmore in the
Mandalorian weathers will be playing the
role of grief carga although the details
of his character are still under wraps
the actor took the podium at this year's
Star Wars celebration in Chicago to
offer some insight into his role saying
he's kind of that ahead of this Guild of
bounty hunters there seems to be a lot
of kind of Nefarious people he's looking
for someone to go after a product for a
client that's very valuable a native of
Copenhagen Denmark Jean Carlo Esposito
has played major parts in huge
television series and lent his trademark
silky smooth voice and Charisma to
several successful motion pitchers he is
perhaps most recognized for his role as
Gustavo Fring the drug kingpin employer
of Walter White in AMC's Breaking Bad
like most facets of the Mandalorian
Espo's role is still largely unknown
however in an interview with collider
the Emmy nominated actor briefly opened
up about his time on set saying I got a
great costume we got great set pieces
I'm not giving anything away because
John Fabro is an artist truly an artist
he was working with George Lucas on this
particular piece and making it a piece
that we can really relate to now in our
world that we're in can you imagine
anyone but Harrison Ford playing the
iconic role of Han Solo in 1977's in New
Hope several high-profile actors were
considered for the part before Ford at
the time a relative unknown landed it
one of those actors was Nick Niti the
star of 1977's the de in an interview
with MTV Niti admitted that he felt he
would have been quote kind of a goofy
Star Wars guy now as it turns out he
will get to be a goofy Star Wars guy in
the Mandalorian though the nature of his
role is still unclear Niti has built up
quite a respectable acting resume over
the years as proven by his three Oscar
nominations he is perhaps most
recognized for his role as Jack Kates in
1982's 48 hours and its 1990 sequel
Another 48
hours you're done end of story although
he is now well into the back nine of his
career NTI is hardly slowing down
appearing over the past decade in
projects like 2015's a walk in the woods
and 2018s the Padre fans of the CW
Supernatural will no doubt recognize
Emily swallow who played the seductive
Archangel slay Amara AKA The Darkness
the 39-year-old actress has also held a
number of minor roles in various
television shows including The Mentalist
and how to get away with murder her big
screen debut came in 2008's the lucky
ones briefly sharing the screen with
Rachel McAdams and Tim Robbins although
details of her character in The
Mandalorian remain shrouded in mystery
swallow's Twitter feed suggests that she
had a great time on set particularly
while working with a special co-star she
wrote working with Tao yti on one of my
episodes of the Mandalorian fulfilled a
very weird and off-kilter dream of mine
after directing the wildly successful
Thor Ragnarok Tao y Titi has become a
household name for fans of comic book
movies in addition to lending his voice
to the hilariously dry Cronin Warrior
corg ytt also made a splash in the
acting world with his role in the 2014
vampire comedy what we do in the shadows
which he also co-directed and produced
as it turns out white Titi who will also
be directing an episode of the series
will be voicing the Droid ig11 in the
Mandalorian Star Wars fans will
recognize this Droid as being a similar
build to ig88 an assassin Droid who was
among the group of bounty hunters hired
by Darth Vader to hunt down Han Solo and
the Millennium FAL in The Empire Strikes
Back German filmmaker wner Herzog is
perhaps best known for his directorial
work overseas including exential dramas
about the human will like 1982's Fitz
coraldo however he has also tried his
handed acting more than a few times like
when he appeared alongside Tom Cruz and
Jack Reacher eagley fans of NBC's Parks
and Recreation might also recognize him
from his Cameo his spooky homeowner keg
jeggins in an episode from the show's
seventh season so this place has had
zero offers people seem to be scared of
on account of it being
haunted when speaking to the Associated
Press Herzog who will be playing a
villain in the Mandalorian applauded the
series as a return to Classic filmmaking
compared to other slick Blockbuster
projects saying the Mandalorian was
filmed not at all like the other Star
Wars or other big event films with green
screen green screen everywhere you see
the landscape you see the formation the
camera could even be handheld and move
in between us seeing the same landscape
it's not green screen and artificiality
it brings movie making back to where it
should be it's a phenomenal phenomenal
achievement although omed abtahi was
excited about Landing a role in the
Mandalorian according to discussing film
he wasn't always a Star Wars fanatic he
told the outlet I hadn't seen any of the
Star Wars films other than the Last Jedi
but when I got off of the role I
realized I had to go and watch them and
fell madly in love with them and now I
am beating myself for waiting so long to
watch it while it's rumored the newly
Meed Star Wars fan will be playing an ex
Imperial intelligence officer named Dr
persy not much else is known of abah's
role the American Iranian actor has
appeared in quite a few movies and TV
shows throughout the 2000s while he is
perhaps best known for his role in the
star series American Gods he has also
appeared in films like 2012's Oscar
winning Argo and 2015's The Hunger Games
Mocking Jay part two you might also
recognize him for his small roles in
various episodes of popular television
series including Better Call Saul in the
Mandalorian Bernard Bolan will be
playing the mysterious role of Father
although this is almost definitely his
most high-profile gig to date the
Spanish British actor is no stranger to
the screen he has appeared in several
television shows both foreign and
domestic and even has a few movie roles
under his belt he briefly appeared on
TNT's The Last Ship and also played an
actor playing Christopher Columbus in
the CW's Jane the Virgin it's unclear
how significant a role he will be
playing in the Mandalorian but Bolan May
well be poised for a major breakout
moment just like the Mandalorian
inaugural season chapters 9 through6 are
peppered with dialogue cold from Deep
deep dives into Star Wars lore here are
just some of the lines that mean more
than you realized but a quick word of
warning before we begin a galaxy of
spoilers are ahead when cob Vamp meets
Mando in chapter 9 he's clearly hoping
things won't get violent in fact he
almost instantly orders quote two snorts
of spotchka for them the weekway
bartender then hands over a bottle of
blue liquid and a couple of Cups while
cob takes a drink Mando never gets to
partake in the beverage but it's still
an interesting illusion to the show's
Premier season season 1's chapter 4 is
the first time that spotchka has
mentioned in the Star Wars Universe it's
a blue drink made from Tiny aquatic
creatures called Krill the Krill
represent the livelihood of the same
Village Mando and carun help protect
from nearby Raiders the call back is
likely intentional considering Mando
finds himself in a similar situation in
chapter N9 by helping a small community
to organize and eliminate a big threat
chapter 9 ends with one of the most
long-awaited reveals in Star Wars
history The Return of boba fats and
consequently the confirmation he
survived his drop into the great pit of
Caron in Return of the Jedi in a
commentary track for the film George
Lucas said that he had considered adding
a scene to show the Bounty Hunter had
survived also in Star Wars books no
longer considered Canon it's explained
that Boba escaped and is still alive
while in the Mandalorian Boba doesn't
reveal how he survived the sarlac it's
possible an exchange between Mando and
Cobb in chapter 9 could give us a hint
when Mando Cobb and the Tuscan Raiders
first arrive at the crate dragon's lir
Mando tells Cobb the Beast lives in an
abandoned sarlac pit cob responds that
he's lived on Tatooine his whole life
and there's no such thing as an
abandoned s pit Mando quickly retorts
that there is if you eat the sarlac it
seems unlikely the great pit of Caron is
the abandoned pit we see in chapter 9
the terrain is a lot different from the
scene featuring the beast in Return of
the Jedi still the Revelation that there
is a creature on Tatooine capable of
eating sarlaac gives us one possible
explanation for boba's survival in the
beginning of chapter 99's final battle
with the crate Dragon Mando utters
something that sounds like a curse as
the Beast begins to back up into his
layer Mando says dank baric it's going
back in it's it's an expression that's
repeated throughout the rest of season 2
by Mando and other characters D fck
while we don't know exactly what the
curse means it's a call back to the very
beginning of the mandalorian's first
episode when we initially hear the
phrase It's spoken by Mando's first
bounty in the series the blue skin
mythrol Mando captures in a bar shortly
after he and his prisoner arrive at the
Razer Crest the fairy that brought them
across the ice is devoured by a
monstrous ravan and looks like Mando's
ship is its next Target as a pair
quickly board the craft the myth roll
yells out thank fck that was close it's
interesting that Mando is now repeating
lines from a former Bounty though he
doesn't quite find himself in the same
situation as the mithil it always seems
like Mando can't take a single step
forward on his journey without doing yet
another job for someone else first and
chapter 10 is no different after his
adventures in and around most pelo Mando
returns to MOS Eisley to find another
lead on mandalorians and a task he has
to perform for the Intel the mechanic P
Moto introduces Mando to someone known
only as the Frog lady who knows where a
group of The elusive Warriors live but
she wants a trip back home in return for
the information as she's giving Mando
the lowdown and what she knows P
translates for him she said her husband
has settled on the Estuary Moon of tras
in the system of the gas giant kiban the
names of both the moon and the gas giant
to references to Heroes from the Star
Wars Legends narrative the Moon tras is
named for tras Olo a character from the
2003 roleplaying video game Star Wars
Knights of the Old Republic tras is an
officer in the galactic Republic as well
as a native of the doomed planet alderon
Cole iban on the other hand is named for
a character from the world of comics
Cole Skywalker he's a Jedi descendant to
both Anakin and Luke who appears in the
Darkhorse comic Star Wars legacy chapter
12 sees the return of a number of
characters including Horatio Sans
reprising his role as the myth rle
Mando's first Target in chapter 1 we
also learned that it was grief Cara who
put up the bounty on the amphibious
alien after grief tells Mando that the
mythr is now working for him to pay off
his debt the Bounty Hunter responds that
he should let him know if the alien
tries to run away again the myth roll
has a a quick comeback to this
suggestion let me assure you I do not
want to spend any more time in carbonite
still can't see out of my left eye this
is a call back to the finale of the
original Star Wars Trilogy Return of the
Jedi after being freed from carbonit in
Java's Palace the panicked Han Solo says
he can't see and Le explains that
blindness is a temporary side effect
from being frozen in carbonite we don't
know exactly how long it's been since a
mythal was freed from Carbonite but it
seems strange he would still suffer
symptoms from the freezing it could be
he's fishing for sympathy or it could
also be a to put grief off his guard in
hopes of a future Escape after all the
myth roll isn't known for his honesty
even if he is telling the truth there's
a good chance neither grief Cara nor
Mando believe him about his bad eye
since they let him drive the speeder on
their way to the Imperial Outpost as
Mando and his companions are on their
way out of the Navaro Imperial Outpost
they come across a lab filled with
deformed bodies floating in tanks in
spite of their tight schedule the heroes
pause to access records to find out what
the lab is actually all about mythb
plays a hollow recording of Dr persing
the Imperial doctor who works on the
child in the first season among other
things persine reports quote there were
promising effects for an entire fortnite
but then sadly the body rejected the
blood I highly doubt we'll find a donor
with a higher M count though by higher M
count Dr persen is referring to one of
the most controversial pieces of the
Star Wars Mythos mic chlorians in The
Phantom Menace we learned that every
Jedi's blood includes higher than
average amounts of M chlorians and that
it's through communication with these
microscopic life forms that Jedi find
their special connection to the force
the fact that this concept still remain
so polarizing among some fans maybe why
persin says M count rather than M choran
count allowing viewers on the thumbs
down side of the debate to imagine m
stands for something else at the same
time the presence of the lab in pin's
recording have fed widespread
speculation that the experiments have
something to do with the cloning of
Palpatine and the creation of supreme
leader snoke chapter 13 of the
Mandalorian sees the long anticipated
liveaction premiere of ahsokatano played
by Rosario Dawson the former Jedi teams
up with Mando against the forces of
magistr Morgan eleth after some close
calls Ahsoka defeats the magistrate in a
duel once she has eleth at her mercy
Ahsoka demands to know one thing now
tell
me where is your
master where is Grand Admiral Thon thraw
is a villain too good to be left on The
Cutting Room floor of Star Wars Canon
the blue skinned Imperial first appeared
in Timothy Zan's thraw novel Trilogy
starting with 1991's heir to the Empire
and concluding with 1993's the last
command while these novels have
officially joined the list of Star Wars
media no longer considered Canon thraw
was also featured in Star Wars Rebels
ahsoka's lines let us know that thraw is
still alive and it's extremely important
that she finds him it could very well be
that ahsoka's hunt for the Admiral will
be the focus of the upcoming Disney plus
Ahsoka Tano series chapter 15 is another
great example of just how far Mando is
willing to go to rescue grou with the
aid of the newly appointed New Republic
Marshall caraun Mando recruits former
foe Ms Mayfield to help him infiltrate
an imperial facility in order toess
access a computer that can give him the
location of mop Gideon once they're
inside Mayfield refuses to approach the
computer console after spotting a former
commanding officer Mando decides to do
it himself and makes a surprising choice
to remove a stormtrooper helmet he's
wearing as a disguise and expose his
face when Mayfield's old Commander
starts questioning Mando he swoops in to
save the day successfully bluffing the
officer into believing they're the
genuine article he also tries to make a
quick work excuse so they can get away
from him come on let's go fill out those
TPS reports so we can go recharge the
power coil mentioning TPS s reports as
no doubt a reference to the 1999 cult
classic office space in the comedy Ron
Livingston plays Peter a passionless
office worker at a software company who
is being hounded by supervisor Bill
lunberg about his TPS
reports yeah you see we're putting the
cover sheets on all TPS reports now
before they go out though decades old
now office bace is often still
referenced and quoted by a wide variety
of fans even in a galaxy far far away in
chapter 15 Mayfield reveals himself to
be a much more layered character than he
originally appears to be in the first
season he and Mando are coralled into
sharing drinks with the Imperial officer
valon Hess the same officer Mayfield
voids earlier we soon learn hes holds an
important place in Mayfield's history
one with such weight in fact that
Mayfield allows it to overtake his
emotions and blow his cover as hes asked
for ideas for toast Mayfield suggests
how about a toast operation Cinder
initially hes seems impressed by
Mayfield turning to Mando and saying now
there's a man who knows his history we
soon learned Mayfield served under hes
during the operation and was traumatized
by what occurred when you find out about
operation Cinder his reaction is
completely understandable it wasn't
something dreamed up specifically for
the Mandalorian but instead has been
mentioned in numerous Star Wars video
games comics and other media Cinder is
Palpatine's contingency plan in the case
of his death to make sure the Galaxy
civilizations don't outlive him weeks
after the battle of Endor the Empire
sets operation Cinder in motion using
satellite arrays to cause disastrous
climate changes on different planets
including the boo no official number has
ever been given for the amount of deaths
but it was clearly significant enough to
make Mayfield shoot hes for his
involvement early in chapter 16 Manda
returns to tras with allies hoping to
enlist the help of the mandalorians he
found there bokatan and Costa are not
happy to see Mando accompanied by Boba
whose voice they recognize is those of
the Clones created on Camino Costa and
Boba exchange a few barbs eventually
leading to a brief altercation before
things get violent Boba warns the
younger Costa to calm down she responds
by saying you'll be talking through the
window of a backa tank backa tanks
aren't to particularly obscure part of
Star Wars lore though you don't often
hear them referred to by name there are
cylindrical tanks filled with backa
fluid which is known for its healing
properties probably the most prominent
use of a backa tank comes early in
Empire Strikes Back when Luke Skywalker
submerged in one of the tanks after
being rescued on the planet Ho by H
solo you might not guess it from the
silhouette but a mandalorian's armor is
as unique as their fingerprints handed
down through generations the distinctive
armor is a defining trait of the
Mandalorian people and their culture
this is the history of Mandalorian armor
explained the mandalorians are a nomadic
people but they're not a species anyone
can be a Mandalorian if they practice
the tenants of their faith before the
Mandalorian Boba Fett was one of the
most well-known mandalorians in the Star
Wars universe but although he wore
Mandalorian armor he didn't really grow
up in the culture and therefore is not a
true Mandalorian because mandalorians
are a warlike people who often act as
mercenaries wearing armor is one of the
six actions Central to their identity
according to Star Wars novelist Karen
Travis the other five are speaking the
Mandalorian language contributing to the
welfare of their Clan defending
themselves and their families raising
their children as mandalorians and
rallying around the sole leader of their
people the Mandalore when asked yet even
though their armor is a central part of
their culture mandalorians like
reminding each other that what's inside
matters most a warrior is more than his
armor is one popular Mandalorian saying
early Mandalorian armor appeared during
season 2 of the Animated Series Star
Wars the Clone Wars the episode The
Mandalore plot showed a mural depicting
ancient Mandalorian Crusaders wearing
helmets over their cloaks as they fought
the Jedi Knights to battle the force
powers of the Jedi the mandalorians
modified their fighting style and
weaponry Clone Wars director Dave Fon
once told comic
book.com the Mandalorian Jedi war that I
have in my mind is very much derived
from the oldest style of thinking of
mandalorians which was that their
weapons their Arsenal their technology
had massive increase once they collided
with the Jedi and found these Force
wielding people that had abilities they
didn't understand filon continued their
armor is a reaction to the Jedi and I've
always believed that because that seemed
to be something that would be in the DNA
of the Joe Johnston designs of them as
super Commandos Johnston who directed
Captain America the First Avenger and
The Rocketeer was was a concept artist
on the original Star Wars Trilogy
incidentally Fon became the showrunner
on the Animated Series Star Wars Rebels
and is now a writer and director on the
Mandalorian both Star Wars the Clone
Wars and Star Wars Rebels delve into
other Mandalorian armor history tied to
the Mandalorian Civil War which split
the group into the pacifist new
mandalorians and the militant Death
Watch although many fans would recognize
a Mandalorian by their armor
specifically the full-face helmet with
t-shaped visor this Schism revealed
other variations particularly in the
helmets for instance the female warriors
of Death Watch known as the night owls
wore helmets with eyelets that would
tilt up like an owls Sabine Ren the Star
Wars Rebels character who is a
Mandalorian warrior and demolitions
expert has a night owl's helmet that she
inherited speaking of Sabine she doesn't
follow the strict helmet rules that
djaren outlines on the Mandalorian
namely that he can't remove his helmet
in front of other people or his vow is
broken and he's no longer part of his
tribe Sabine often goes without her
helmet even though she usually wears her
armor a mandalorian's armor includes a
lot of accessories the helmet for
instance has a c link with an antenna it
also includes night vision a tactical
display facial and vocal recognition a
fingerprint scanner video recording
links to vehicles and weapons and flight
controls for the jetpacks that
mandalorians use to be more maneuverable
in battle in the man Oran Den Jaren
receives a jetpack from the armorer at
the end of season 1 which he uses to
fight against moth Gideon Mando fares
pretty well considering that he's still
learning the controls unlike the
undignified trajectory of Boba Fett in
Star Wars Return of the Jedi one key
part of the mandalorian's Arsenal is the
van brace a wrist Gauntlet Cho full of
various Weaponry including a 25 M long
retractable fiber cord flamethrower
energy Shield protector trackers laser
targeting sights launchers for
tranquilizing or explosive darts a mini
Rocket Launcher motion detectors
repulsors a communication system and a
touchscreen display next to its
well-known silhouette Mandalorian armor
is also known for its toughness thanks
to bestcar a material that's also called
Mandalorian iron or Mandalorian steel
bestcar protects against Blaster shots
as well as lightsaber strikes but it's
also lightweight allowing the wearers to
be much more agile than say Tony Stark
learning to fly in his mark one suit in
2008's Iron
Man okay this is where I don't want to
be yikes bestcar has such remarkable
strength because of both its natural
properties and Mandalorian metal working
techniques djaren causes a stir when a
client pays him and bars of bescar
another Mandalorian remembers how the
rare metal could be mined only on their
home planet of Mandalore and was likely
stolen during the Great Purge in the
mandalorian's first episode the armorer
uses a bar of Besar to forge a new
pauldron or shoulder plate for Mando the
colors and markings on Mandalorian armor
can be highly varied and are often used
to express lineage or State of Mind
according to Travis that said
mandalorians also decorate their armor
according to taste they'll repaint their
armor if they change Clans or if they're
on a particular task Sabine Ren for
instance often changed her Armor's
markings much like she changed her hair
color
adding a prominent Insignia in her
starboard design a precursor to the
emblem of the Rebel Alliance blue and
green are popular armor colors for
mandalorians who like to be conspicuous
Travis wrote referencing another
Mandalorian saying it's one thing to see
us coming and another to do something
about it Mandalorian armor doesn't just
provide protection it's also an heirloom
because bestar can last for hundreds of
years as Sabine Ren once said the armor
I wear is 500 years old I reforged it to
my liking but the battles the history
the blood all lives within it and the
same goes for every Mandalorian Travis
explained in Star Wars Insider that as a
nomadic people mandalorians frugally
invested much of their wealth into their
armor and weapons this was certainly
practical because they could take their
earnings with them early in the
Mandalorian Mando receives a large
payment of Besar after delivering the
child to the mysterious Imperial client
after Mando presents the bestar to the
armorer she suggests that she can craft
a full quass for him plus whistling
Birds a type of mini missile the excess
he donates to the foundlings the orphan
children the mandalorians protect
catching up afterward with grief carga
head of the bounty hunters Guild Mando
draws several stairs over his shiny new
threads but he's really just following
the investment strategy of ancient
mandalorians besides caran notes the
grumblers are just jealous that they
didn't get all that loot mandalorians
love personalized armor saine Ren
embraced this part of Mandalorian
culture throughout Star Wars Rebels and
not just through her signature design
Rebels fans know that she kept the
Armor's insulating Body Glove but
Stripped Away a lot of the other pieces
for maximum Mobility she also upgraded
her helmet's Electronics although she
used the video and image recording
abilities to capture her artwork much
more than the targeting viewfinder on
the Mandalorian the armorer has
strikingly distinctive armor from the
fur across the back plate to the shape
of her eyes on her helmet polygon notes
that her helmet also appears to have
zabra horns which could be a reference
to Darth Maul a zra who briefly ruled
Mandalore and headed the death watch on
Star Wars the Clone Wars Mandalorian
armor often has sigils or symbols
painted on the chest plate or helmet
indicating their lineage Allegiance or
even awards for bravery according to
Travis the armor can also have a signate
specifying the wearer's particular Clan
when the Mandalorian begins djaren has
no signant even though he was adopted by
the mandalorians as an orphan was
trained as a warrior and joined their
tribe he starts the first season as a
classic Western Lone Wolf archetype that
changes once he meets the child who uses
his Force powers to help Den defeat a
charging mud horn a creature that
resembles a gigantic Rhino when the
armorer suggests that he has earned the
mud horn as a signate for failing the
creature he declines saying that it
wasn't a noble kill but once Den has a
chain of heart and retrieves the child
from the Imperials who want his power
the armorer decides that Den is worthy
of such an honor she forges a mud horn
signate for him and instructs him to
take care of the green foundling and to
return the child to his own kind if
possible in the meantime she says you
are a clan of
two over the past four decades Star Wars
has spawned plenty of movies animated
shows and video games but liveaction
television has always been the one
unconquered Frontier in the Star Wars
Universe at least until now at Star Wars
celebration 2019 showrunner and Creator
John favro repeatedly emphasized that
the Mandalorian will be one giant love
letter to the original Star Wars Trilogy
and that tribute extends behind the
scenes as well bavro wants to make sure
the Mandalorian feels like our first
visit to that galaxy far far away
naturally green screens and CGI are
necessary to deliver the Mandalorian on
a TV budget but favro says that the crew
is also using puppets animatronics and
special effects makeup wherever possible
for example while the dog fights in the
modern Star Wars films are mostly
computer generated favro really wanted
to make a model of the razor Crest to
use during production well industrial
Light and Magic's art staff were so
excited about the idea that they didn't
just make a model unprompted they went
home and built a camera rig in their
garages recreating the hardware that was
used to make Star Wars back in 1977 the
end result looks just like classic Star
Wars films you'll see this is this is
done Isn't that cool it already feels
like Luke's X-Wing right ilm's staff
aren't the only Star Wars fans who got
in on the Mandalorian action either the
show's producers reached out to the 50
First Legion a group of Star Wars fans
who make their own highly detailed
Stormtrooper outfits Lucas film has
teamed up with the 50 first before for
promotional events but the Mandalorian
marks the first time that the 501st has
appeared on screen in an official Star
Wars production all of Star Wars owes a
huge debt to George Lucas after all he
created the thing but the Mandalorian
has some specific ties to Star Wars
maker for one the show is heavily
inspired by the first Star Wars movie
especially the opening act and the
Cantina scene however as John Carlo
Esposito has revealed Lucas's input on
the series goes a lot deeper than that
according to Esposito Lucas actually
contributed some creative ideas to the
show while discussing the Mandalorian
with collider Esposito said that John
favro quote figured it out with George
Lucas himself and worked directly with
him to make sure the show felt like
classic Star Wars Star Wars and video
games have always enjoyed a healthy
relationship and the Mandalorian pushes
it to the next level while John favro
and his team used practical effects as
much as they could to capture the
original Star Wars handmade charm dig
Wizardry was key in bringing the
mandalorian's Exotic worlds to life but
how did favro and the actors know what
their fictional locations were supposed
to look like by using a game engine of
course video game software is great at
rendering detailed 3D environments in
real time and the Mandalorian team used
that Tech to create digital sets that
the casting crew could film and see the
results in real time not only did that
speed up production but it let the
Mandalorian creative minds get an
excellent read on what the finished
product would look like and adjust
accordingly the results should speak for
themselves thanks to Boba Fett we knew
what a Mandalorian looked like decades
before we knew anything about them as a
people and the Mandalorian wouldn't be
the same without him Boba Fett debuted
during the Star Wars holiday special and
while the rest of the program isn't
worth your time nana Studios animated
short the faithful wook absolutely is
not only does the sequence make fet
cooler than the movies ever did but the
design ended up influencing both how the
mandalorians looked on the Clone Wars it
also set the standard for the
mandalorian's costume that narrow visor
the big old holster the natural color
scheme and the visible battle damage
those are all from his old short it also
gives an idea as to what the Mandalorian
might look like in fact Nana's animators
look to westerns when storyboarding the
short the faithful Wookies surreal
Landscapes and the dinosaur that Boba
rides might be a little too fanciful for
liveaction action TV but if you want to
see Star Wars reimagined as a spaghetti
western you don't have to wait for the
mandalorian's premiere there's already
an example out in the wild if you're
worried the Creator John favro isn't up
to the task of bringing Star Wars to the
small screen don't be he's got some help
longtime Lucas film president Kathleen
Kennedy is listed as one of the show's
producers and all of the material will
still go through Lucas film's story
group the organization in charge of
keeping Star Wars cannon consistent
favro is also getting a big big hand
from the animated side of things Dave
filon may not be a household name but if
you're a modern-day Star Wars fan you
know his work filon directed The Clone
Wars feature film and he worked side by
side with George Lucas to bring the
subsequent animated series to the air
Fon also co-created both Rebels and the
newest Star Wars cartoon resistance in
other words he's the guy behind a lot of
the best parts of modern Star Wars Canon
according to the art of Star Wars the
Clone Wars filon is the brains behind
Anakin Skywalker's beloved Apprentice
Ahsoka Tano on Rebels filon and his
staff raised questions about the Jedi's
relationship with the force years before
Ryan Johnson and The Last Jedi did the
same revenge is not the Jedi
way I am no Jedi heck he even voiced
Chopper Rebels scen stealing Droid filon
is serving as one of the show's
executive producers and he'll make his
liveaction directing debut by helming
the mandalorian's very first episode The
Mandalorian takes place about 5 years
after Return of the Jedi and 25 years
before the force awakens making the
Galaxy a very different place than what
you're used to the ragtag Rebel Alliance
has transformed itself into the new
Republic a representative democracy that
spans many known planets the Galactic
Empire on the other hand hasn't been as
fortunate after the battle of jaku
brought the Galactic Civil War to a
close what remained of the main Imperial
Fleet retreated to the mysterious
unknown regions where it will eventually
reform into the first order not yet
though the first order is still years
away it's a time of transition out on
the Outer Rim where the Mandalorian
takes place former Imperial Warlords are
scrambling to hold on to power former
Rebels are trying to figure out where
they belong now that the fighting is
stopped criminals try to profit off the
confusion and the mandalorian's main
characters are all caught right in the
middle of it the Mandalorian isn't even
out yet and it's already a hit or at the
very least Disney seems extremely
confident that it'll be one months
before the Mandalorian debuted John
favro got the green light to start
writing season 2 by the time the cast
and crew started making the rounds to
promote the first season filming on the
second was already underway season 2
adds a couple of new directors to its
already stacked lineup for one favro
will actually get to helm in episode or
two of the series this time around
during season 1 he was too busy on
Disney's The Lion King to take a direct
role behind the camera the Mandalorian
cast member Carl Weathers will also
direct a season 2 installment in fact
his interest in sitting in the
director's chair was one of the main
reasons why he joined the series dreams
are worth fighting for now are you going
to be a fighter or are you going to be a
doctor you're right Carl Weathers favro
promises that there are plenty of
surprises and a few old Legends
characters in the pipeline don't give up
on the Mandalorian when season 1 ends in
December the show is just getting
started
just three episodes in the new season of
the smash Disney plus hit the
Mandalorian has continued to see Mando
and the child exploring Parts yet unseen
in the galaxy far far away it's also
found them encountering creatures too
frightful to mention for those who fear
things with more than four legs chapter
11 of the Mandalorian thankfully took a
bit of a break from the Creature Feature
Fantasia that dominated the first two
episodes well sort of titled the ays the
latest entry in Mando 's quest to return
the child to his people saw the duo
hitting the high seas and indeed running
into yet another beastly foe luckily
Mando also ran into some people of his
own as he and the child are helped out
of their jam by a band of Mandalorian
allies while this episode of the
Mandalorian expands the world of the
weapon worshiping religious sect in
fascinating new ways the arrival of
those helmet issuing allies undoubtedly
delighted diard Star Wars fans because
there are some very famili Amar Clone
Wars names involved Chief among this is
Bo Katan who featured prominently in the
Beloved animated series as the head of
house PR and former Regent of Mandalore
what are you waiting for get out
there she was also the one-time wielder
of the dark saber whose history she also
details in the erys while Star Wars fans
were no doubt elated to hear the story
and see batan in the flesh they were
likely just as happy to see the face of
the actor portraying the Fearsome
Warrior as she also voiced the character
in the Animated Series her name is Katie
sackoff and any true sci-fi fan should
be quite familiar with her face here's
why Bo Katan from the Mandalorian looks
so familiar if you do call yourself a
true sci-fi fan Katie sack off's face is
probably familiar to you because it was
often front and center on one of the
best loved sci-fi programs of the past
two decades that series was Ronald D
Moore's utterly brilliant modern up date
of the classic Sci-fi Saga Battlestar
Galactica which found the last remnants
of Humanity on the run from a murderous
race of manmade Android enemies and in
Desperate search of a fabled planet that
may serve as Mankind's new home I've
been to
Earth I know where it is the series
premiered on sci-fi back in 2004 and
quickly became a massive hit with both
fans of the original 1970 show and those
who had never heard of AD dama a
syons or Viper Fighters even if they'd
never heard those names it's possible
they had heard the name Starbuck before
not only from the pages of Herman
Melville's iconic novel Moby Dick but
also because the hot shot Viper Pilot's
name was probably the most prominent to
arise from the original Battle Star
Galactica series portrayed by Dirk
Benedict in the original series Starbuck
got a much needed modernizing for the
Sci-Fi series reboot with more
transforming the Shire pilot into a
fearsome fem the likes of which sci-fi
fans had never really seen before and
yes Katie sack off was the actor tasked
with resurrecting the character for the
new battl Star Galactica to Simply say
she did that would be a gross
understatement though more than any
actor in the series zakov didn't just
resurrect her character she wholly
reinvented it delivering what can only
be described as a towering performance
almost too big even for the Epic series
around it of course if you somehow slept
on Battlestar Galactica over the years
it's possible you recognize sack off
from a plethora of other notable small
screen turns as the actor has also
appeared on the likes of longm 24 and
most recently Netflix's another life she
also turned up in a certain CW arse hit
as one of DC comic's toughest
underground kingpens that arse hit is
none other than the flash which means
the underground in question belongs to
Barry Allen's hometown of Central City
and yes that was indeed Katy sack off
portraying the nefarious amunet black on
the hit CW drama a metahuman with
significant power amunet black was the
premier dealer of weaponizing tech on
Central City's black market and
therefore supplied many of Team Flash's
foes with the destructive tools of their
villainous trades in turn amunet Black's
business dealings more often than not
put her in direct conflict with Barry
and his allies in spite of her prominent
role in the Central City City underworld
Zack off's character appeared in just
six episodes of The Flash during its
seven season run on the CW most of which
came in the series fourth season but
even in such a limited capacity Zack off
more than made her mark on the series
crafting a villainous as ruthless
Relentless and delightfully devious as
any that has ever faced off against
Barry and his do Gooding gang even if
the character doesn't always get the
respect she so richly deserves while
Katie sack off has largely made her name
on televis
the actor has managed to rack up some
impressive big screen credits over the
years she actually got her first big
break after landing a key rooll in
2002's flawed but fun Halloween sequel
Halloween resurrection and a sense
appeared in genre Delights like 2013's
Ric and 2016's Gothic Chiller don't
knock twice if you want to see Katie
sack off at her big screen best however
look no further than the 2013 creeper
she made with Mike Flanigan yes that
Mike Flanigan the very genre master
Mastermind behind such modern horror
classics as hush Gerald's Game Dr sleep
and Netflix's breathtaking The Haunting
of Hill House series before delivering
those frightful Delights to the masses
Flanigan actually scored a modest hit
with a little haunted mirror creeper by
the name of oculus it's understandable
if the term haunted mirror made you
cringe a little and the initial setup of
Flanigan's Oculus which follows a woman
attempting to clear her brother of
murder charges by proving the culprit
was actually the haunted artifact in
question really is a bit silly but if
Flanigan has proven anything over the
years it's that he can turn even the
silliest of premises into a soul
stirring and genuinely terrifying
cinematic treat that's just what
flanakin does with oculus delivering a
haunted mirror Marvel that simply has no
business being as effective as it is
Flanigan bolsters the film's impact by
pulling brilliant turns from his cast
including Karen Gillan Brenton dates
Rory Cochran and a never better Katie
sack off as The Tragically departed
family
matriarch The Saga of the planet
Mandalore is spread across 90s comic
book series tales of the Jedi the
animated series The Clone Wars and Star
Wars Rebels and the liveaction series
The Mandalorian here is the history of
Mandalore explained after the runaway
success of the original Star Wars in
1977 the future was wide open of for
sequel The Empire Strikes Back among the
many abandoned concepts for the second
part of the original trilogy was an army
of Imperial Super Troopers armored
badasses from the Mandalore system as
conceived by George Lucas and designed
by visual effect supervisor Joe Johnston
and concept artist Ralph mcquary the
Super Troopers would have an ancient
grudge against the Jedi and an array of
weapons integrated into their suits to
combat them these Concepts would end up
forming the basis of mandalorians as we
know them much later but at the time the
budget simply didn't exist to
manufacture dozens if not hundreds of
these new costumes which were were much
more intricate than the Stormtrooper
outfits created for the first film the
idea of Super Troopers was scrapped but
the design was undeniably great and a
new individual character was conceived
to wear it the Bounty Hunter Boba Fett
the costume was given some color and
some wear to it to give it a sense of
history and to distinguish it from
proper Imperial attire like Sith or
Palpatine the words Mandalore and
Mandalorian are never uttered in the
original trilogy but fans came to know
it and Associate it with the armor
through the wealth of ancel material
released about the film Universe
throughout the 1980s and '90s you may
take Captain solo to Java the Hut after
I have Skywalker he's no good to me dead
the fact that Boba Fett says and does
very little in his first two film
appearances did nothing to dampen fan
enthusiasm to learn more about him and
the origin of his slick armor the
original Star Wars expanded universe
comprised of novels Comics video games
and tabletop RPG Source books published
between 1978 and 2014 offered an
enormous amount of information about the
Bounty Hunter and the culture from which
he hails the mandalorians their home
world of Mandalore became the setting of
many stories and home to an army of
characters wearing variations on the
Beloved costume design Mandalore is
established to be a planet on the outer
rim of the Galaxy and the namesake of an
entire sector of space a temperate
earthlike World Mandalore is notable for
being the exclusive home of a near
indestructible metal called bescar from
which his resident warrior culture
constructs their armor the Mandalorian
religion demands war and conquest and
Mandalore becomes the seat of an
expanding Empire during the Old Republic
era thousands of years before the
Skywalker Saga this leads to war against
the Sith the Jedi the Republic and
frequently themselves as Mandalore lacks
a central government in the year 738 BBY
the Jedi and Republic resolved to
preempt the threat of Mandalorian
expansion by bombarding their core
worlds including Mandalore itself the
Mandalorian exision leaves their empire
in Ruins by the time of the Clone Wars
the surface of Mandalore is a Barren
desert its remaining cities are housed
beneath giant domes and generations of
resentment still exists between the
mandalorians and the Jedi however this
may not have always been the case as at
least one Mandalorian served the Jedi
Order a thousand years ago around the
height of the Old Republic the
Mandalorian Jedi named tarisa invents a
unique lightsaber called the dark saber
that becomes a legendary totem a sort of
Mandalorian Excalibur after Tara's death
the dark saber is in tuned with the Jedi
Temple on corusant but is later
liberated by his descendants and
returned to Mandalore where for
Generations its wielder commands a
respect of all Mandalorian Clans the
blade is either passed down through
inheritance or one through single combat
while there is only one dark saber
traditional armor is also built
specifically to mimic or counter the
abilities of the Jedi it repulses mimic
a force push while its flamethrower is
difficult for Jedi to Parry with a
lightsaber the best guy used to create
this armor is likewise passed down and
recast across Generations a generation
before the Clone Wars break out across
the Galaxy Mandalore is wrenched by a
civil war of its own devastating the
population when the war is over a peace
movement builds momentum across the
planet leading to the birth of a new
pacifist government mandalorians who
still wish to follow their Warrior
tradition are exiled from the planet to
its Moon Concordia where they rally
behind the dark saber and form a rogue
fighting force Called Death Watch The
pacifist new mandalorians are led by
Duchess satin cre and appointed prime
minister om whose reforms reshape
Mandalore to a society more closely
resembling that of peaceful and
prosperous worlds in the core of the
galactic Republic when War breaks out
between the Republic and the Confederacy
of independent systems satin insists
that Mandalore remain neutral and
becomes the leader of the Council of
neutral systems as the designated Regent
of 1500 systems I speak for thousands of
Worlds that have urged me to allow them
to stay neutral in this war this
decision allows the new Mandalorian to
remain pacifists but it also ends up
cing them in other ways as it strains
their diplomatic relationship with the
Republic nearly to its breaking point
and both sides in the Clone Wars bar
mandalorians from using their space
lanes for trade the public is forced to
rely on an expensive black market for
goods a practice for which prime
minister om is eventually arrested and
removed from office the death watch's
leader preizler sees the new pacifist
Mandalore as weak and disgraceful and
seeks a way to return to the home world
and seize power however death watches
ranks are thin and Satine is a popular
leader vler finds an ally in Count Dooku
leader of the Coalition of independent
systems and they hatch a plot to turn
the public against the tetin and open
the door for his triumphant return to
Mandalore Dooku and vizla arrange a
bombing on mandor prompting satin and
visiting Jedi obiwan Kenobi to
investigate they discover that Death
Watch is behind the bombing and that the
CIS may be involved which prompts the
Republic Senate to consider installing a
military presence on Mandalore against
the teen's will in order to keep the
planet out of separatist hands this is
all part of Dooku's plan since a rep
public occupation would be enormously
unpopular among the Mandalorian public
Death Watch would return to rid the
planet of the Invaders throw Satine
under the bus and take charge with the
full support of the people satin Kenobi
Anakin Skywalker and Padme amadala
managed to unravel this plan and
dissuade the Senate from approving this
Invasion after this failure Count Dooku
Cuts ties with preisler and deathwatch
Retreats deeper into the Mandalorian
sect
during their travels across space Death
Watch happens upon a craft carrying two
wounded passengers former Sith
Apprentice Maul and his own charge and
brother savagea press like a vler mo
hates the Jedi and holds a bitter grudge
against Obi-Wan Kenobi sensing an
opportunity vler invites Mo to team up
and retake Mandalore which would provide
Mo an opportunity to take revenge on
Kenobi Mo accepts and formulates a plan
similar to dukus arranged for a massive
crime wave on Mandalore that is beyond
Dutchess satin's peacekeepers capacity
to repel therefore allowing Death Watch
to return as conquering Heroes preisler
endorses the plan offering Death Watch
as muscle to force the Galaxy's three
biggest crime syndicates to cooperate
the scheme goes off without a hitch as
the crime wave turns a public against
the team's pacifist leadership and gives
preisler the opening he needs to clean
up the mess and win their support Death
Watch is here to save you from these
Intergalactic gangsters that threaten
our great City Once he's thrown Satine
in jail and taken the throne for himself
viszla attempts to dispose of Mo and
Opress but finds he's underestimated
them mo always planned to consolidate
the syndicates and to use mandal La as
the seat of his new Criminal Empire and
to him it's vizla who's outlived his
usefulness Mo kills vizla in ritual
combat winning the dark saber leadership
of Death Watch and the Mandalorian
Throne Mo keeps this new found power a
secret from the public reinstalling
goldmakers as puppet prime minister
while much of Death Watch Falls in line
behind their new leader preisler
Lieutenant both batan cre refuses to
follow an outsider and leads a splinter
group against all batan Springs her
sister Duchess satin from prison who in
turn summons a starcross lover Obi-Wan
Kenobi to Mandalore this too plays into
M's hands as it affords him the
opportunity to kill Satine in front of
Kenobi simultaneously eliminating a
political rival and punishing his Jedi
arch nemesis the attempt to quickly
remove Mo from power is unsuccessful and
Kenobi and batan Squad are forced to
flee mandor months later batan convinces
the Jedi Council to lend her a battalion
to help her and seat Mo as ruler of
Mandalore aided by Clone Commander Rex
ex Jedi adviser ahsokatano and a segment
of the 501st Legion Ban's remaining
loyal Warriors lay Siege to the capital
city of sundari they are met by Mo's
Death Watch led by gar Saxon of house
viszla ahsokatano captures Mo after a
hard fought lightsaber door while batan
easily takes a throne room from relative
pushover alch with with their leadership
removed and their forces overwhelmed by
the combined might of bokatan
mandalorians and the Republic's clones
Mo's forces surrender the Republic named
batan the new Regent of Mandalore
nominally granting the planet the
self-determination they crave as they
escape from under the boot of M's Shadow
Collective the siege of Mandalore ends
mere days before the fall of the
Republic and its Reformation into the
Galactic Empire which quickly shatters
any illusions of Mandalorian
Independence when batan refuses to
follow emperor palatine's orders she is
stripped of her Regency and replaced by
a new Imperial Governor M's former right
hand gar Saxon Saxon creates a new Army
of Mandalorian super Commandos
repurposing the armor and traditions of
Death Watch to serve the Empire and to
punish any Mandalorian clan that doesn't
fall in line behind the New Order one
group of Warriors the protectors is
permitted to go about their own Affairs
and carry on Mandalorian Traditions as
long as they are in tune with Imperial
interests why would I fight the Empire
when obviously destroying you is is so
much easier when they're discovered
allowing the Rebel Alliance to use their
hyperspace Lanes the entire Clan is
wiped out Mandalore also plays host to
an imperial Academy which not only
trains Storm Troopers and potential
super Commandos but also conducts
research and development for new weapons
and Technology one Academy student
Sabine Ren developed a weapon called The
Ark pulse generator which fires burst of
energy that seek out bescar armor
superheating it and incinerating anyone
inside while leaving any other
combatants totally untouched eager to
prove her Brilliance Sabine builds a
working prototype but when she realizes
that the Empire might actually use it
against Mandalorian she destroys it and
leaves Mandalore to become a bounty
hunter and eventually a leader in the
Rebel Alliance Mandalore spends nearly
two decades tightly under Imperial rule
it once proud Clans brought to heal by G
Saxon and his super Commandos Saxon
makes an example of Clan Ren after
saine's affection sabine's father is
imprisoned and her brother Tristan is
conscripted into the Super Commandos in
order to assure Clan Ren's cooperation
how can you wear that armor Tristan how
could you join them you shouldn't have
come back Sabine meanwhile Sabine
herself has been fighting the Empire as
a member of Phoenix Squadron during
their travels her team happens across
the dark saber which has been missing
for quite some time Sabine learns to
wield the saber as a weapon but feels
ill suited to use it for its symbolic
purpose to Rally all mandalorians to her
command she brings the weapon back to
her mother urur Ren's home on crones in
the hopes of recruiting Clan Ren into
the Rebel Alliance gar Saxon intervenes
but he is defeated in single combat by
Sabine and then killed by Ursa before he
can shoot Sabine in the back Clan Ren
begins to openly oppose the Empire which
brings other clans to their aid
including Clan cre still led by batan
together with sabine's Jedi friends Ezra
Bridger and Kanan jarus Clans Ren and
cre return to Mandalore and defeat a
plot by its new Imperial Governor G's
brother Tyber Saxon to use sabine's
aruls generator against against
Mandalore after this Victory batan
accepts the dark saber and a number of
Clans pledge loyalty to her and her
fight to free Mandalore from the Empire
little is yet known about the fate of
Mandalore after the start of botan's
rebellion but it does not appear to have
gone well a decade after the Clans unite
to oppose the Empire mandalorians have
been all but wiped out after an event
referred to as the great perge during
which the Empire slaughtered countless
Mandalorian and forc the remainder into
hiding the mandalorian's first season
reveals that a small tribe of
mandalorians live in secrets on the
planet Navaro leaving their underground
home only one at a time in order to hide
their numbers this tribe which may be
one of many practices a much more strict
form of the Mandalorian religion than
that demonstrated by other mandalorians
seen to date these mandalorians aren't
even permitted to remove their helmets
except in private this is the way
further evidence of the damage to
Mandalore and its people is the Empire's
rating of its prized resources officers
of the now fallen Empire now possess
large quantities of bescar stolen from
either Fallen Warriors or the planet
itself which they sld back to
Mandalorian in exchange for their
service as bounty hunters as seen in the
season 1 finale the dark saber itself
was landed in the possession of moth
Gideon during the second season of The
Mandalorian Mando's quest to return the
child to his people leads him to Tres a
watery Moon where he and the child
almost meet their Doom before they're
saved by a trio of mandalorians led by
Bo Katan Mando is shocked when his
saviors immediately do their helmets
revealing themselves to be adherents of
a very different sort of creed but
they're able to set aside their
disagreements long enough to make a deal
if he helps them raid an ex-imperial
ship and steal Weaponry they'll put him
on the right path toward a Jedi who can
potentially train the child Mando's new
allies have more in mind for the raid
than they're letting on of course as
batam reveals when she accurs the ship's
commander and demands to know where MF
Gideon's holding the artifact she needs
to claim her rightful place at the
Mandalorian throne but the commander
kills himself before he can be forced to
reveal any information it's a
disappointing setback although with
Gideon hunting Mando and batan searching
for Gideon it's more than likely their
paths will cross again and reveal more
about the history and current fate of
Mandalore the Mandalorian is a series
that focuses on djarin but it's also
pulled in Beloved characters from many
different areas of the Star Wars
Universe here are a few season 2
characters that mean more than casual
fans might think Star Wars has always
been a space Western but the Mandalorian
episode The Marshall takes it even
further here we meet a gunslinging space
Marshal named cob vanth with the Empire
fallen and Jaa The Hut taken down taten
is left with a bunch of mining
syndicates vying for power someone had
to set things straight after the
resistance took down the Empire so why
not a space Sheriff though the episode
is fance first onscreen appearance in
the Star Wars Universe he originally
appeared in Chuck wendig's Cannon
Trilogy aftermath there we learned that
van is a former slave and has been
protecting free town from Red Key
Raiders even though though it is
unlikely that most fans of the
Mandalorian have read the aftermath
Trilogy we still may see more of fans
part of the Galaxy in upcoming Disney
plus content a straight up space Western
might be just what we need in a galaxy
far far away the mandalorian's Frog lady
may not have a meta backstory within the
Star Wars universe but her struggle
speaks volumes about the state of the
Galaxy following the Savage rule of the
Empire frog lady is on a simple mission
to deliver her eggs back to the Moon
tras because this clutch of eggs is the
last of her life cycle she's desperate
to keep the eggs safe from harm no
pressure and no help from grou who
seemingly never met a creature he didn't
want to eat frog lady provides us with a
deeply personal look at the state of
civilization throughout the Galaxy much
of the Star Wars franchise focuses on
massive battles without shining much
light on the aftermath of that
destruction how many other species are
almost completely wiped out after the
Empire's destruction not all species
eliminations come from the massive blast
of a death star and frog lady shows us
how deep deep and vast the herd
following War can be for the beings
caught in its wake it's not often that a
Jedi leaves the order but then again
Ahsoka Tano is no ordinary Force wielder
Ahsoka first appeared during the 2008
animated film Clone Wars which spawned a
TV series of the same name while
ahsoka's final scene in the Clone War
series finale leaves her journey
open-ended viewers do know Anakin
Skywalker's former pan has left her role
as a Jedi completely behind yet as we
see in the Mandalorian she doesn't
abandon the force Rosario dorson assumed
the role of Ahsoka for the Mandalorian
for the show's 13th episode the Jedi and
when she appears for the first time
Ahsoka wields a pair of white
lightsabers which she purified from Dark
Side crystals Cannon projects like Clone
Wars comic books and novels have
introduced fans to numerous force
wielders and their lightsabers but
Ahsoka is a force sensitive character
who's actively wielding the force while
rejecting the Jedi way her choice to
follow her own rules leaves room for
fascinating story lines and car
characters that don't jive with Jedi
beliefs the former Jedi left her mark on
the Mandalorian by shedding light on the
life of the child when she revealed his
true name and his passor to Padawan at
the Jedi Academy that was just the
beginning Rosario Dawson's aoker is
getting a very own self-titled show on
Disney plus Valen hes may be a new
character for the Mandalorian but what
he represents goes far beyond his
character scope Star Wars has a
significant number of villains but most
of them are pretty one-dimensional we
all hate Grand MF Tarin the RO less
Imperial Naval leader but beyond a few
scenes where he demonstrates his cunning
nature or talks about military tactics
we don't get a sense of who he is we
often don't know why characters who
represent the Empire do the things they
do outside of fear and the lust for
power so it's interesting to hear from
some lower level villains in chapter 15
The Believer Mando has to sneak into an
Imperial base with former Imperial
Sharpshooter Mi Mayfield and before the
pair can sneak back out they're cornered
by Hess who was once Mayfield's Superior
officer when Mayfield asks hes how he
could sacrifice his entire division to
wipe out a city hes replies you see boys
everybody thinks they want freedom but
what they really
want is order H toast the Empire at
which point Mayfield shoots him dead but
before that hessa's monologue offers a
rare glimpse into the mindset of the
Empire's military commanders and it's
chilling even though his answer doesn't
come as a surprise given that the
Mandalorian focuses on characters who
have reasons for avoiding the new
Republic after the fall of the Empire
it's un surprising that we don't see
many former Rebels pilot carena and his
wingman Trapper wolf are exceptions
along with others from the rebel ranks
who helped take down the Empire the pair
now monitors going on in an official
capacity policing a Galaxy healing after
Decades of strife Mandalorian viewers
introduced to the duo in chapter 10 the
passenger when Mando's attempt to avoid
them nearly gets him eaten by a giant
space spider it isn't just that he's
feeling shy after T and and Wolf Rescue
him we find out there's a warrant out
for his arrest when Bando asks T if he's
going to try and take him into custody
the pilot admits he ought to but For
Better or Worse the new Republic is far
from the authoritarian regime that the
empire was and T lets him go this
encounter is more than a glimpse at
Republic police work in action the
Mandalorian also threw in a fun Easter
egg for fans to discover longtime Star
Wars writer and Mandalorian producer SL
occasional director Dave filon plays
trapple wolf and with the upcoming Star
Wars Disney plus series Rangers of the
new Republic which will take place
during the same time as the Mandalorian
and the sooka we may see a lot more of
these two we all know Boba fetta is
important but let's be real he's pretty
tame in the original trilogy he stumbles
over his armor he barely says a word and
he's accidentally bested by a blind hun
solo as far as villains go Star Wars has
done better but is he really a villain
the original trilogy made it clear that
he was only in it for the money however
given his urge to help Mando and the
Warriors code of ethics he shows in the
Mandalorian it's hard not to wonder if
the Empire forced his hand following his
surprise return and subsequent role in
rescuing grou from MF Gideon Boba Fett's
slate is now clean and he returns to tne
to take over Jaba the Hutz Palace we've
yet to learn what the former Bounty
Hunter has been up to all these years
was he stuck in the digestive track of
AAC for several years or did he escape
relatively quickly after Han launched
him into the pit perhaps his motives
aren't as pure as they might seem he
does save fenic Shand noting that they
were both left for dead in the desert
maybe he was once a villain everyone
believed him to be but he's clearly been
changed then again the teaser for this
Disney plus series The Buck of boa Fett
suggests otherwise he's a little too
smug when he kills bib Fortuna and
claims his throne what does it take to
stop assassin fenx Shand from killing
people for money a near a death
experience apparently but better a
change of heart later than never if fenx
Shand has actually changed her tune we
briefly learn about the Assassin in
season 1 of the Mandalorian and we
discover that that she's a mercenary
who's already killed for the Huts it's
not until season 2 that her character is
more thoroughly fleshed out fittingly
given that Shand is named after the
desert dwelling fenic Fox the Assassin
is Sly and her motives are often unclear
while Shand isn't exactly a hero she
does have some kind of code the
mercenary follows Boba Fett after he
saves her from death and she even puts
her life on the line to help Mando find
grou when mof Gideon's dark Troopers
kidnap him both she and Boba Fett are
incredibly hard to read but hopefully
the book of Bo be Fett will answer all
of our burning questions Star Wars fans
who haven't tuned in to the Animated
Series clone wars and Rebels might not
be able to guess by her appearance in a
Mandalorian but batan cre is kind of a
big deal of Mandalore batan is devoted
to returning Mandalore to its former
glory and she's taking on the likes of
Darth Maul to prove it by the time we
see her in the Mandalorian batan is in
pursuit of the dark saber which has
being wielded by m Gideon it's a quest
that grows more complicated after Mando
becomes its rightful owner by defeating
Gideon in combat during the season
finale then tries to give her the weapon
but as a delighted Gideon points out the
dark saber must be won not given it's
unclear at the close of season 2 just
how much Mando's ownership of the dark
saber will mean for Mandalore and batan
but any conflict between the two won't
be the first time they've clashed when
they meet she scoffs at Mando's refusal
to take off his helmet basically
accusing him of following a cult-like
faction of Mandalorian tradition being
faced with botan's assertion that you
can be a Mandalorian without shielding
your face from the Galaxy marks the
first time Mando really questions his
Storch beliefs the question lingers as
we see him remove his helmet twice after
that conversation particularly in the
poignant closing moments of the season
finale when he removes it in order to
give grou a proper goodbye Disney build
the rise of Skywalker is the swan song
to The Skywalker Saga Ray even buries
Luke and Leia's lightsabers putting
their story line to rest it wasn't
subtle yet the Mandalorian second season
finale brought her to reemergence of the
the Skywalkers in a major way Luke
himself saunters onto mof Gideon ship
decimating an entire platoon of dark
Troopers in his response to Gru's call
it's clear from the minute a hooded
figure brandishes a green lightsaber
that Luke is under the shroud of mystery
but many fans were still thrilled to see
him remove his hood looking and sounding
just like he did in Return of the Jedi
while the moment is one of Triumph it
also poses the question just how far
will this go will Disney be whipping out
CGI Luke in another 30 years if Luke is
fair game then who who else are they
going to CGI back into existence with a
slew of Disney Plus shows on the horizon
including Obi-Wan Kenobi and Lando it's
hard not to wonder whether the Skywalker
era will ever be over and while for
Nostalgia sake that's a great comfort it
also might prevent other great stories
from emerging the bottom line Disney may
have been skewing the truth when they
said the rise of Skywalker was the end
of the Skywalker story but fans still
have to admit the scene was still pretty
epic djaren the mandalorian's tit Bounty
Hunter has had a wild ride since he
crossed paths with the child also known
as grou luckily jarn has a variety of
weapons to protect himself and his
little companion let's take a look at
some of jarn's gear but be warned
spoilers are ahead Mandalorian helmets
have long been associated with the Star
Wars Creed and jaren's helmet is no
exception just like with any other
Mandalorian helmet jarn features a
t-shaped visor and entirely conceals his
face also jarn's tribe follows the way
of the Mandalore a religion where
members are not allowed to remove their
helmets in public if they do they can
never put them back on again why you ask
this is the way this is the way jarn has
been seen without his helmet in public
only twice so far in chapter 8
Redemption because he was badly injured
and needed a Droid to tend to his wounds
and in chapter 15 The Believer to bypass
an imperial security scan Mando's helmet
also comes with a variety of features
such as tracking heat signatures long
range audio and detecting recent
footsteps left on the ground these perks
are especially useful when Jaren needs
to locate nearby individuals whether
they be enemies or those in need of
assistance jaren's Mandalorian armor not
only looks cool but it is also extremely
durable it's made out of a powerful
metal alloy called bescar which is known
to withstand Blaster fire and even the
might of a lightsaber since jarn's armor
is badly damaged in the show's sophomore
episode he brings a large payment of
bescar to his tribe's armor who uses it
to craft a new quas instead of having a
red and gray color scheme in the vein of
his previous armor this shiny new armor
is metallic silver just like his helmet
in Redemption the armor announces the
formation of jaren's Clan Clan mudhorn
which is made up of himself and the
child to coincide with this formation
the armor inscribes the skull of the mud
horn on his right pauldron as his Signet
jarn's dual flamethrowers have come in
handy time and time again for instance
in chapter 3 the sin jarn uses a
flamethrower to torch an attacking
Stormtrooper he's even been known to
bring the heat when words fail him you
understand
this easy
easy like any weapon in Star Wars
however flamethrowers have their limits
after Jaren is surrounded by bounty
hunters who all want the child he uses a
flamethrower to drive them away but it
runs out of juice when he needs it most
while Boba Fett first used a iation of
this weapon in the animated segment from
the infamous Star Wars holiday special
the amben phase pulse blaster in the
Mandalorian seems to be much more
powerful throughout the course of the
series jarn uses this sniper rifle to
either incapacitate or disintegrate
anyone who stands in his path these
enemies can be big as a TR oan or as
small as a Jawa both of whom were killed
in the same episode Jaren also uses the
Blaster to tase a wide variety of
Intergalactic enemies and creatures such
as Stormtroopers and even a crate Dragon
when Jaren returns to the Mandalorian
hideout with his best gar payment the
armorer uses the excess material to
build him a special weapon whistling
Birds these small guided Munitions are
placed in his left VRA when deployed the
projectiles fly through the air while
making a whistling sound before striking
their targets and detonating a small
explosive the armorer Tells jarn that
these projectiles are rare so he saves
them for desperate moments Star Wars
fans have often Associated jetpacks with
Mandalorian culture yet Jaren didn't
receive his own until the final episode
of season 1 in Redemption the armorer
asks Mando if he has ever trained in The
Rising Phoenix to which he promptly
responds that he did when he was a boy
the armor then gives Mando a jetpack and
sends him on his way to reunite the
child with its own kind the jetpack
comes in handy later in the episode when
Jaren uses it to attack a TIE fighter
that's piloted by moth Gideon Jaren also
uses the jetpack in the subsequent
episode when he flies out of the belly
of an angry crate Dragon however despite
all of its advantages in Warfare the
best part about the jetpack is watching
the child's ears flop around when Mando
takes him for a ride flash charges
aren't exactly common place in the Star
Wars universe but for Jaren they are
especially useful in chapter 5 the
Gunslinger this episode sees Mando
working with aspiring Bounty Hunter Toro
cakan to capture a wanted assassin named
fenick Shand they soon discover that
Shand is using a farway ridge as a
makeshift sniper nest after Nightfall
jarn and cakan use Flash charges to
Blind Shen so they can apprehend her
before long cakan decides to betray
Mando jarn blinds kakan with a flash
charge and takes him out it's not a big
loss for the Galaxy though in fact M
could probably sum up cakan in two words
W rat jarn's whip cord has helped him
get out of many deadly situations in
chapter six The Prisoner for example
Jaren takes on several New Republic
security droids throughout the fight
Mando uses the grappling hook to behead
one Droid and uses it again to bring
another one closer to a Droid that's
being incinerated jarn later finds
himself locked in a jail cell luckily he
escapes after he uses his whip cord to
tether a security Droid near his cell
door he then rips off one of its arms
which he uses to open the lock grenades
are probably one of the most important
weapons for jarn in fact we've seen him
reach for them in wildly different
circumstances one instance where they
were especially useful happens in
chapter 11 the ays when Jaren bokatan
cre and two other mandalorians
infiltrate an Imperial cruiser
transporting valuable weapons after
flying to the ship the four Warriors try
to take the ship's bridge but end up
encountering a squad of Storm Troopers
armed with heavy repeating blasters all
while the captain is attempting to crash
the ship at the behest of moth Gideon
jarn quickly devises a plan to get
himself and the others to the bridge he
asks the three Mandalorian to cover him
as he charges toward the remaining
Stormtroopers after getting close enough
Jaren throws two grenades at the enemies
blowing them up and creating a path to
Victory when speak speaking of
self-preservation a wise man once said
Pokey religions and ancient weapons are
no match for a good Blaster at your side
even though Jaren knows next to nothing
about the so-called hokei religion he
almost always has a blaster at his side
as he demonstrates many times throughout
the show Jaren is very proficient with
his Blaster pistol in fact the initial
fight scene that kicks off the entire
series features Mando using his pistol
to shoot the control panel of a door
which then slices a quaren tler in half
and that's just the first of many
memorable scenes of Jaren relying on his
pistol to save the day and the
[Music]
child